bonjour à tous s'il y a bien un thème
qui a agité le Sénat depuis la rentrée
de septembre pendant tout l'automne
c'est bien le non cumulle des mandats
petit retour en arrière au mois de
septembre les sénateurs examinent le
projet de loi sur le non cumul des
mandats en première lecture ils adoptent
finalement le projet de loi mais il
s'exclu du dispositifs s'en suit la
commission mixte paritaire et alors
députés et sénateurs ne parviennent pas
à se mettre d'accord le texte repart
pour une nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés alors et bien
reviennent à la version originale du
texte le texte doit maintenant revenir
au Sénat à priori au mois de janvier on
en parle avec le sénateur UMP Philippe
Bas bonjour bonjour donc ce texte ne va
pas être examin n'a pas été examiné
avant les vacances du mois de décembre
il ne va revenir qu'au mois de 2 janvier
est-ce que ce n'est pas un petit peu une
manière de reculer l'issue fatale
c'est-à-dire que le texte et bien
finalement va être adopté dans la
version de l'Assemblée nationale nous
ferons tout en tout cas pour donner une
chance au compromis vous savez que le
Sénat en
1985 comme en 2000 a approuvé les deux
précédentees loi restreignant le cumul
des mandats alors que c'était un sénat
de la droite et du centre et un gouvern
de gauche nous ne sommes nullement
hostiles à de nouvelles restrictions en
matière de cumulle ce que nous rejetons
c'est l'interdiction absolue d'exercer
une fonction exécutive locale et un
mandat parlementaire car nous ne voulons
pas de parlementaires hors sol qui n'ont
pas un contact régulier avec les
réalités du service de nos concitoyens
dans les collectivités locales
effectivement puisque
constitutionnellement les sénateurs
représentent les tivité territoriale
c'est inscrit dans l'article 24 de la
Constitution c'est ça que vous mettez en
avant absolument il y a deux assemblées
en France ça n'est pas le cas dans tous
les pays une assemblée démocratique qui
représente les territoires c'est le
Sénat et une assemblée démocratique qui
représente directement le peuple mais le
Sénat pour autant n'exige pas qu'il y
ait un traitement différent entre les
sénateurs et les députés nous sommes
tout à fait prêts à un compromis qui
permettrait que députés et sénateurs
exer
un mandat exécutif local regardez un
médecin peut être maire et pourtant il a
beaucoup de travail un notaire un chef
d'entreprise mais pour une commune par
exemple de 5000 habitants ou de 2000
habitants le seul qui ne pourrait pas
être maire c'est celui qui représente
les collectivités territoriale au Sénat
il y a quelque chose d'absurde dans ce
dans ce raisonnement qui a été fait
parce que c'est un raisonnement
idéologique et si le gouvernement au
lieu de camper sur une position qui
exclut tout dialogue avec le Sénat
accepterit la recherche d'un compromis
je suis sûr qu'il pourrait le trouver
euh néanmoins a priori le texte va donc
être adopté dans la version de
l'Assemblée nationale quel va être
ensuite et bien le recours des sénateurs
opposés donc à à ce n cumule des mandats
je crois que ce serait violé la
Constitution que de donner le dernier
mot à l'Assemblée nationale sur des
dispositions de loi organique relatives
au Sénat et ce n'est pas moi qui
l'invente c'est l'article 46 de la
Constitution qui le dit donc si le
gouvernement et la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale s'entêtait et bien
il faudrait que le Conseil
constitutionnel rende son arbitrage et à
ce moment-là s'il devait comme je crois
qu'il le ferait constater une
irrégularité du point de vue de la
constitution dans la procédure du
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale il
faudrait en quelque sorte rejouer la
partie et le compromis qu'aurait refusé
le gouvernement il serait bien obligé
d'aller le chercher au Sénat alors donc
recours constitutionnel mais est-ce
qu'il y a pas un recours peut-être
encore plus important celui de l'opinion
publique manuel Vals le ministre de
l'intérieur lorsque il est venu ici au
Sénat a plusieurs fois invoquer cette
opinion publique hostile à la classe
politique dans son ensemble et hostile
notamment au cumulle des mandats est-ce
que vous entendez cet argument ce type
de chantage est parfaitement détestable
il y a pas d'un côté ceux qui peuvent
parler au nom des Français et de l'autre
ceux qui n'ont pas le droit de le faire
en réalité les Français se prononcent
massivement pour leurs députés maire
pour leurs sénateurs maire à chaque
élection et si on voulait gouverner
uniquement en fonction des sondages
encore faudrait-il tenir compte de la
réalité de ces sondages de l'intensité
du désir des Français moi je crois que
nous n'avons vraiment rien à craindre du
jugement des Français qui apprécie
d'avoir des élus qui connaissent les
réalités et qui ne sont pas en
apesanteur merci beaucoup Philippe B
d'avoir répondu à nos questions tout de
suite retour donc à cette séance le
projet de loi sur le non cumule des
mandats première lecture au Sénat au
mois de septembre monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les
sénateurs souvent trop
souvent des voix se font entendre pour
critiquer mettre en cause caricaturer
les élus il serait trop
nombreux coûterait trop cher il
n'agirait pas
assez serait
incapable d'entendre de comprendre les
attentes des
citoyens de les entendre et d'y répondre
ce faux
procès ce procès injustifier que l'on
fait aux élus de la République nous ne
l'acceptons pas je ne l'accepte pas et
jamais nous de devons nous y résoudre ce
qui implique nécessairement agir et
d'agir ensemble la démocratie n'existe
pas sans ses élus elle n'existe pas sans
ses parlementaires sans ses élus locaux
et la démocratie c'est ce lien de
confiance ce contrat qui unit qui doit
unir à tous les niveaux les citoyens à
ceux et à celles qui ont la charge de
les représenter et de veiller au sein au
destin de la
collectivité la démocratie c'est
l'expression de la volonté du peuple et
les élus sont les porteurs de la volonté
du peuple cette volonté dont parlait
mIRABO et à laquelle on ne peut rien
opposer de plus grand de plus fort et de
plus juste notre démocratie cette
magnifique redécouverte de l'Antiquité
par la modernité s'est construite pas à
pas elle a su s'imposer mais elle a su
aussi évoluer s'adapter j'ai honneur
d'être devant vous aujourd'hui après son
examen et son adoption par l'Assemblée
nationale pour vous présenter un texte
de loi qui fera date oui il fera date en
mettant un terme au possibilité de
cumulle entre les fonctions exécutives
locales et le mandat de députés ou
sénateur ce texte vient profondément
renouveler le fonctionnement de nos
institutions et de nos pratiques
politiques ce projet loi est une
véritable avancée démocratique et c'est
le mérite autant que le devoir de la
démocratie de toujours veiller avancer
améliorer son fonctionnement approfondir
le lien qui existe entre les élus et les
citoyens ce lien peut prendre plusieurs
formes je ne vous apprends rien il
existe notamment dans les territoires au
travers des collectivités locales les
élus locaux et vous êtes nombreux à
l'être ici j'ai l'occasion d' mes
fonctions de les rencontrer très
régulièrement sur le terrain je sais
combien quelle que soit leur sensibilité
ils sont dévoués donne de leur temps et
de leur énergie au service de l'intérêt
général je les Ren compte notamment dans
des situation où il faut faire face aux
difficultés à l'adversité ce fut le cas
par exemple en juin dernier en
hautegaron et dans les hautes pérénées à
la suite des inondations qui ont frappé
ces deux départements dans les campagnes
dans les villages dans les bourgs alors
que les équipes de secours étaient
mobilisées les élus locaux étaient là au
côté de population pour aider paraî au
plus pressé je pourrais prendre
évidemment d'autres exemples être élu
local de sa commune de son canton de son
département de sa région c'est être à
l'écoute de la collectivité qui vous a
accordé sa confiance c'est gérer le
quotidien tout en préparant l'avenir
moimême même élu local depuis 25 ans je
sais le degré d'exigence que revê de
telle
mission gérer le quotidien c'est
s'occuper des cantines scolaires veiller
à la tranquillité publique répartir les
créneaux sportifs ou encore résoudre des
problèmes de voirie ou d'assainissement
préparer l'avenir c'est se mobiliser
pour le développement économique
travailler à l'attractivité d'un
territoire le doter des équipements
publics scolaires sanitaires et les
infrastructures adaptées et je veux
rendre un hommage tout particulier aux
maires des petites communes qui ont
souvent sur leurs épaules le poids de
lourde responsabilités des
responsabilités qu'ils assument la
plupart de temps à titre bénévole ou
presque et en plus de leurs activités
professionnel je ne supporte pas cette
démagogie qui vise nos élus locaux et de
même je neis pas les attaque qui vise le
Parlement faire la
loi contrôler l'action du
gouvernement évaluer les politiques
publiques sont des missions essentielles
pour notre démocratie notre démocratie
qui s'appuie sur cet équilibre entre le
pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
législatif le travail parlementaire que
l'on appartienne à la majorité ou à
l'opposition implique investissement
rigueur connaissance approfondie des
enjeux le Parlement ce n'est pas que le
lieu d'interpellation du pouvoir
exécutif c'est un lieu de réflexion de
discussion de prise en compte des points
de vue de tous les points de vue c'est
le lieu de la construction patiente de
nos lois des lois qui doivent tout
prévoir tout envisager c'est le lieu de
l'édification de la concrétisation de la
volonté générale la démocratie a besoin
de ses élus de tous ses élus en dépit de
la défiance les Français le savent bien
ils ont besoin de leurs élus et la
démocratie mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs c'est la confiance
confiance dans les institutions
confiance dans des élus présents dévoués
et qui respectent leurs engagements or
comment ignorer fermer les yeux sur
cette crise de confiance qui touche nos
concitoyens il doute de la capacité de
la politique avoir une emprise sur leur
destin il doutent aussi de la capacité
de leurs élus à agir cette crise de
confiance il nous appartient à tous d'y
répondre répondre en réformant nos
institutions cela a déjà été fait par le
passé c'est ce que nous faisons avec ce
projet de loi oui véritable révolution
démocratique j'en ai bien conscience
tout avancé si elle est trop brusque
peut-être
déroutante mais cette avancée
démocratique n'est en rien brutale ce
n'est pas une surprise elle est la
traduction du 48e engagement de campagne
d'un engagement fort du président de la
République
elle a l'assentiment de nos concitoyens
qui attendent cette réforme et
d'ailleurs le président de la République
sortant et d'ailleurs le président de la
République sortant lui-même c'était
avancé sur cette voie qui attendent des
actes conformes à ce que Pierre mandz-
France appelait le contrat de
législature gage d'une république
moderne et oui c'est vers une république
moderne que nous voulons all une
république qui décide d'en finir avec
une spécificité française le cumul qui
avec le temps est devenu une
singularité vous ne manquerez pas de
rappeler que comme d'autres j'ai cumulé
vous irez exhumer président mard je vous
vois prêt à bondir des
citations des propos tenus des
articles rien
n'enlèvera rien nenlèvera et rien ne
m'enlèvera de la fierté que j'ai de
porter aujourd'hui ce
texte et de concrétiser l'engagement
pris par François Hollande devant les
Français cet
engagement il est le fruit d'une
réflexion à laquelle comme d'autres j'ai
contribué modestement en effet j'avais
été chargé par ma formation
en février 2011 d'un rapport sur la
modernisation de nos institutions et
j'ai fait 10 proposition et la première
de ces propositions c'est l'interdiction
du cumul d'un mandat parlementaire et
d'un mandat au sein d'un exécutif local
et cette proposition avait déjà été
adoptée elle a été confirmée par le vote
des militants de ma formation
politique
dans
dans vos
argumentaires dans vos argumentaires
vous citerez sans doute le président de
la République peut-être même le Premier
ministre vous ne manquerez pas d'évoquer
le cas de l'ancien président du conseil
général de la corz et ses positions
passées ce que François Hollande
souhaitait à l'époque du débat au sein
de sa formation politique c'était que
cette disposition du non cumule
s'applique à tous
par la loi et pas un seul parti et c'est
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui cette
avancée s'inscrit par ailleurs de
manière cohérente dans un mouvement
d'ensemble mise en œuvre par le
gouvernement avec le soutien de la
majorité il s'est traduit ces derniers
mois par l'instauration de la parité
pour l'élection des conseillers
départementaux par l'extension du
scrutin liste pour les communes de plus
de 1000 habitants vous y avez contribué
par l'élection directe des conseillers
intercommunaux vous y avez contribué par
l'extension enfin du scrutin
proportionnel aux élections sénatoriales
la majorité sénatoriale adopté cette
disposition être fidèle à la République
c'est un spécialiste qui doit parler à
ses traditions ce n'est pas regarder
vers un passé fantasmé ce n'est pas
sarquebouté sur des pratiques devenues
obsolètes
encore concumuler moins sous la 3e et la
4e République non être fidèle à la
République c'est regarder vers l'avenir
c'est sans cesse en adapter les
institutions à la modernité il s'est
même trouvé une majorité qualifié au
Congrès en 2008 avec des parlementaires
de gauche pour adopter la réforme
constitutionnelle présenté à l'époque
par le président Nicolas Sarkozi c'est
la tâche à laquelle dans tous les
domaines je m'attelle depuis mon arrivée
au ministère de l'Intérieur depuis
plusieurs mois nos institutions se sont
réformées et nous franchissons donc
aujourd'hui une nouvelle étape j'ajoute
que l'interdiction du cumul a été
préparée par deux lois antérieurs les
lois organiques du 30 décembre
1985 et du 5 avril 2010 porté par des
majorités de gauche qui ont limiter les
possibilités de cumul de la limitation
nous voulons passer nous devons passer à
l'interdiction cette avancée
démocratique est aussi le prolongement
logique de 30 an de lois de
décentralisation qui ont affirmé et la
place et le rôle des collectivités
territoriales dans notre paysage
institutionnel 30 ans de loi de
décentralisation auquel différentes
majorités ont contribué qui ont fait
qu'un membre d'un exécutif local s
assumer des responsabilités de plus en
plus complexe de plus en plus prenante
être maire être président vice-président
d'une assemblée départementale ou
régionale c'est nécessairement se
trouver de manière continue au contact
de la collectivité dont on a la charge
ce sont des missions qui mobilise à
pleinemps de même et plus encore depuis
la réforme constitutionnelle de 2008
c'est pourquoi j'y faisais
allusion le mandat national de députés
et de sénateurs et vous le savez très
bien est devenu plus exigeant encore
nous devons prendre acte de cette
réalité
elle s'impose à nous
être
parlementaire être membre d'un exécutif
local ce sont des fonctions qui ne sont
plus superposable le faire c'est au
mieux
déléguer le plus souvent à
l'administration au pire survoler et on
ne peut pas se satisfaire de cela les
citoyens de toute sensibilité Politi le
disent clairement cette avancée mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs c'est une
avancée pour notre démocratie et pour la
5e République le mouvement a été amorcé
par l'Assemblée nationale qui en
première lecture à la surprise de
beaucoup d'ailleurs ici notamment a
adopté ce texte par
3 ce
mouvement vous le prouverez alors ce
mouvement est
inélectable l'Assemblée nationale a
d'ailleurs enrichi ce texte elle l'a
parfois durci je pense à l'extension du
principe de non cumule aux fonctions
dérivées du mandat local qu'il s'agisse
des EPCI enans fiscalité propre des
syndicats mixtes des établissements
publics locaux des sociétés d'économie
mixte local des sociétés publiques
locales ou encore des organes de gestion
de la fonction publique
territorial je le dis parce que certains
ne semblent pas avoir lu le texte adopté
en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale vous a fait bien de le
lire comme ça vous le savez
bien avec le débat que nous ouvrons
aujourd'hui mais je vous trouve en
pleine forme ça augure bien du débat le
Sénat ainsi l'occasion de prendre toute
sa part dans ce mouvement le Sénat a
l'occasion de poursuivre son œuvre
décentralisatrice en dotant notre pays
d'élus locaux à pleintemps l'occasion
aussi affirmer à nouveau la place de la
chambre haute dans les institutions de
notre
République saisir cette occasion c'est
faire preuve c'est faire preuve de
courage vous en aurez d'autres c'est
j'eni bien conscience de dépasser des
réticences c'est aussi éviter un certain
nombre de pièges et de renoncer mesdames
et messieurs à certaines illusions la
première de ces
serait de croire que nous pouvons
encore repousser ce débat je l'ai dit
cette réforme est attendue par nos
concitoyens pour
beaucoup pour beaucoup nous n'avons que
trop
tarder je sais que certains parmi vous
souhaiteraient que nous attendions
encore cela n'est plus
possible ce texte vous le connaissez
vous avez pu y travailler il a été
présenté Conseil des ministres le 3
avril dernier il a été examiné par
l'Assemblée nationale début juillet et
surtout vous connaissez ce texte c'est
la procédure normale car le Sénat a déjà
eu l'occasion de se prononcer sur son
contenu en tout cas déjà sur une version
proche en effet le 28 octobre 2010 le
Sénat décidait déjà de renvoyer en
commission la proposition de loi
organique de Monsieur Jean-Pierre belle
qui n'était alors pas président de votre
assemblée comme le texte d'aujourd'hui
celui d'hier visait interdire le cumul
de mandat parlementairire avec
l'exercice d'une fonction exécutive
locale comme aujourd'hui certains
estimaient déjà que le plus urgent était
d'attendre au nom d'une prochaine étape
de la
décentralisation au nom d'un futur
statut de l'élu voire au nom d'une
réforme constitutionnelle et bien moi je
crois que cette réforme est justement
une clé pour faire évoluer terme nos
institutions et nos pratiques vous me
direz comme certains l'ont dit hier
qu'il faut que tout change mais ce
serait la formule etconnue pour que rien
ne change en 2010 dans sa motion de
revoie en commission le doyen Géard
estimit que le Sénat je le cite devait
approfondir sa réflexion sur un texte
qu'il jugeait intéressant je crains que
nous n'entendions les mêmes propos plus
tard dans notre discussion
et pourtant me semble-t-il le Sénat a
approfondi sa réflexion il a eu le temps
pour cela comme
toujours comme toujours vos travaux ont
été placés sous le signe du
sérieux de
l'profondissement je pense notamment au
rapport de vos collègues François Noël
buffet et George labazé le titre qu'ils
ont souhaité donner à leur travail
résume d'ailleurs bien les enjeux dont
nous aurons à parler au cours de nos
débats oui les mandats locaux seront
bien valorisés par le non cumule lors de
l'élaboration de ce projet de loi nous
avons débattu de la date de son
application vous n'ignorez pas que des
voix se sont exprimées ça sera encore le
cas sans doute pour une application dès
la promulgation dès les municipales de
2014 j'ai personnellement souhaité pour
des raisons politique et juridique que
cette mise en œuvre n'intervienne qu'à
compter de 201 après le renouvellement
de l'Assemblée nationale des raisons
juridiques d'abord nous ne faisons que
suivre la recommandation pertinente du
Conseil d'État la formule qui vous est
proposé garantit l'exercice du droit de
suffrage assure la continuité du
fonctionnement des assemblées évite tout
risque de rétroactivité une raison
politique ensuite il était essentiel de
laisser à chacun le temps de réfléchir
de prévoir de s'organiser
deuxème illusion
dangereuse l'idée d'un traitement
différencié du Sénat j'ai pris
connaissance avec attention des
amendements déposés sur une majorité de
banc je sais évidemment que nous allons
avoir ce débat que certains voudront
exclure les sénateurs des règles de non
cumule que d'autres sur des bancs
différents proposeront divers seuils de
population je dois vous le dire
d'emblé le gouvernement non seulement
s'opposera à ses amendements ch
souverain mais il est totalement
déterminé à préserver l'équilibre de ce
texte jusquau bout je parlais d'illusion
il est en effet illusoire de croire que
le Sénat puisse s'exonérer d'un
mouvement de fond qu'il puisse seul
continuer de vivre sur des règles du
passé cela je le répète ne serait pas
compris de nos concitoyens et cela
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
je vous le dis sincèrement serait
également néfaste pour le Sénat lui-même
nous le répéterons sans doute souvent
dans nos discussions le Sénat représente
les collectivités locales de la
République c'est la lettre de l'article
24 de la Constitution c'est aussi l'un
des fondements de notre République et
j'y serai fidèle mais si vous le savez
parfaitement représenter les Collectiv
territoriale ce n'est pas nécessairement
en diriger une en drroit le Conseil
constitutionnel a me semble-t-il déjà
tranché cette question sa jurisprudence
sur ce point est claire la
représentation des collectivités
s'exerce par le collège électoral des
sénateurs composé essentiellement d'élus
locaux pas par l'exercice d'un mandat ou
d'une fonction surtout nous devons
penser à la place du Sénat dans nos
institutions le Sénat français et je
pense que vous êtes attaché à ce
principe n'est pas le bundestrat
allemand il n'est pas la seconde chambre
d'un régime fédéral il est la chambre
haute d'une République décentralisée
comme l'a souhaité l'un des vôtres et la
différence est de taille c'est sur cette
idée que se fonde la conception
républicaine du Sénat c'est sur cette
idée que le Sénat a pu progressivement
exercer des prérogatives parlementaires
proches de Cell de l'Assemblée nationale
différencier pour la première fois de
l'histoire de notre République de cette
5e République le régime des
incompatibilité applicable aux députés
et sénateurs faire du seul Sénat une
chambre d'élus locaux ce serait
précisément battre en brèche ce principe
ce serait remettre en cause le bicamise
équilibré à la française et à terme ce
serait sans doute renoncé à la plénitude
de la compétence législative du Sénat et
pour mémoire je vous rappelle que le
Bundesrat allemand n'examine qu'environ
un tiers des textes fédéraux et je ne
pense pas que cela soit votre ambition
pour le Sénat et vous feriez erreur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs si
vous considériez que le texte que le
gouvernement vous présente affaibli le
Sénat car vous le savez et vous le savez
parfaitement ce texte sera adopté en
dernière lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale avec les principes et les
équilibres qui vous ont été donnés et
c'est pour ça que vous devez accom exte
quel que soit le vote qui sera le vôre
ce texte sera adopté il renforce le
Sénat 3è
illusion 3è illusion 3è illusion adopter
le nom cumule reviendrait à préparer la
voix à des élus coup des
réalités à ce que
certains s'il vous plaît nous aurons le
débat je vous écouterai avetion
dans la discussion générale je prendrai
évidemment non seulement plaisir à ce
débat mais intérêt à vos analyses à vos
arguments à vos
propositions trè illusion adopter le N
cumu reviendrait à préparer la voix à
des ulus coup des réalités à ce que
certains se plaisent à appeler des
apparatiques je n'aime pas ces mots je
mot je n'aime pas ces mots il dévalorise
la fonction d'élu et le choix des
citoyens ou le choix des élus qui
élisent les sénateurs et puis les appara
chqu qu'est-ce que c'est qu'on me le
dise est-ce un statut existe-t-il une
définition quelle est la prochaine cible
les
zenarc les fonctionnaires en
général les membres de cabinet
les
héritiers et bien vous aurez ce débat et
vous devrez les uns et les autres
signaler précisément quelle est la
prochaine cible parmi les élus parmi les
élus et bien au moins les choses sont
claires je trouve que je ne suis ni
héritier ni aparach ni
éar ici il n'y a que des élus des femmes
et des hommes on des parcours politiques
pour la plupart dans des formations
politiques qui ont choisi de faire de
leur vie l'engagement politique et donc
ces termes d'apparachic ne sont pas
dignes du débat public ce catalogue
c'est celui des populistes celui que
brandissent sans cesse les ennemis de la
démocratie parlementaire comme ils l'ont
toujours fait ici dans ce pays on est
libre de se présenter si on est français
au suffrage universel et on est libre de
lire qui on veut et il faut pas rajouter
des catégorie à ces principes qui sont
simples là encore la crainte doit être
dissipée je ne crois pas que le sénateur
ou le député de demain celui qui
n'exercera pas de fonction exécutive
locale sera horors sol dépourvu de
contact avec ses concitoyens la
proximité nécessaire aux élus elle est
le fondement de leur légitimité elle le
restera à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat par
le mode d'élection et puis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs 40 % des
sénateurs d'aujourd'hui ne seraient pas
concernés par l'application de ce texte
soit qu'il n'exerc pas de mandat local
soit qu'ils sont conseillers municipal
départemental ou régional sont-ils pour
autant de mauvais sénateurs sont-ils
inaptes à légiférer sont-ils coupés de
la réalité non bien éendu de même les
maires de grande ville et je citerai
Paris Bordeaux Toulouse ouins pour des
raisons différ
sont pas parlementair sont-il de mauvais
élus locaux non mesdames et messieurs
ces élus seront des élus à temps plein
proche de leurs électeurs à leur écoute
des élus aussi qui auront le temps le
temps de légiférer pour les un et pour
les autres le temps d'exercer un mandat
local prenant et bien sûr passionnant ce
temps ne suffira sans doute pas et je
sais qu'il faudra aussi adapter
certaines règles es pratiques le travail
parlementaire sera naturellement
bouleversé et il faudra doter et c'est
de votre compétence de votre
responsabilité les députés et les
sénateurs de moyens nouveaux notamment
pour le contrôle de l'exécutif il
devrait être possible de rémunérer des
collaborateurs bien formés capable
d'assister les parlementaires dans ce
contrôle pour les élus locaux la
question du statut de l'élu se pose
nécessairement président de la
République l'a d'ailleurs dit l'ordre de
vos états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale et cette idée a déjà été
traduite dans la proposition de loi de
Jean-Pierre Sueur et Jacqueline gourau
il faut la poursuivre dans cette voie et
sans doute l'approfondir ces élus
nouveaux à temps plein sont attendus par
les Français et dès 2014 car il ne fait
aucun doute que cette forme produira ses
premiers effets politiques lors des
prochaines élections locales déjà dans
nos villes dans nos département on pose
peut-être pas partout mais en tout cas
dans de nombreux territoires la question
au candidats continuerez-vous à cumuler
vous nous accorderez tout votre temps
quel que soit je le répète la décision
que prendra le Sénat cette question
deviendra habituel banal et il vous sera
impossible de l'éluder cette question
vous devrez je le dis modestement
l'avoir à l'esprit lorsque vous vous
prononcerez sur ce texte mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs j'aborde ce
débat comme vous je le constate dans la
sérénité et dans un esprit de respect
respect du Sénat bien sûr mais aussi
respect des Français et des engagements
que nous avons pris devant eux ce débat
vous l'avez compris je l'aborde
également avec détermination la
détermination apportter une réforme que
je crois moderne et historique la
réforme est souvent déroutante à priori
mais rien
n'interdit avec le temps après
réflexion après mû réflexion de dépasser
les réticences initiales je connais les
réticences mais je crois qu'il temps de
le de les dépasser et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce débat est une
belle occasion pour les dépasser et pour
moderniser notre vie politique et nos
institutions merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole à Monsieur le Président de la
commission des lois Jean-Pierre
suur
monsieur le Président du Sénat messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues j'aborde ce
débat avec respect pour les positions
des uns et des autres comme c'est
l'habitude au
Sénat c'est un débat auquel chacun a
beaucoup
réfléchi qui partage notre assemblée qui
partage un certain nombre de groupes en
leur sein qui partage même certains
deeuxmêmes avec eux-mêmes car beaucoup
sont dans l'interrogation où l'ont été
longtemps et donc ce n'est pas un débat
simpliste ni
maniquen je veux d'abord dire cela parce
que chacun finalement réfléchit à partir
de son expérience
il m'est arrivé d'être élu député d'être
réélu deux fois sans exercer aucun autre
mandat et un maire de mon département
m'a envoyé une lettre un jour il a même
fait un discours enflammé en disant vous
êtes député mais vous n'êtes pas mare
donc vous n'êtes pas vraiment
député j'ai médité tout cela et après
quel un échec
je me suis efforcé mes chers collègues
de devenir maire alors j'ai dit aux
collègues
voilà il m'est il m'est
arrivé d'être longtemps député et que
député maire et seulement maire et
sénateur et seulement
sénateur vous
savez je dois dire que d'ailleurs
Jean-Michel beayy me le rappelit dans
cet itinéraire les les électeurs ont eu
quelque part et ils m'ont toujours donné
un mandat important je leur en suis
reconnaissant bien j'ai donc aussi vécu
chers collègues le fait d'être à la fois
maire et député pendant 1 an et demi
j'ai vu que c'était quand même assez
difficile d'être à la fois maire de
grandeeville et parlementaire tout le
monde tout le monde le sait
et fort de cette expérience mes chers
collègues je peux
ajouter on en a déjà parlé dans cet
éémicycle que j'étais heureux aux
dernières élections sénatorial d'être
élu y compris au premier tour y compris
au scrutin
uniominal sans exercer aucun autre
mandat que celui de sénateur mais on m'a
dit mais tu as exercé d'autres mandats
avant et c'est la vérité autrement dit
quand vous prenez un parcours qui
j'espère n'est pas encore à Chever un
parcours chacun va raconter son parcours
on aura quantité
d'expériences qui permettent de montrer
que un on ne peut pas tout faire en même
temps ça c'est vrai que deuxièmement il
faut être présent sur le terrain mais le
fait d'être sénateur et seulement
sénateur n'empêche pas je le disais hier
avec à Éric d'liget de d'aller visiter
10 semaines 10 10 communes dans un seul
weekend de faire comme nous le faisons
tous et toutes des permanences pour être
à l'écoute des élus mais aussi des
salariés des chefs d'entreprise des
artisans des commerçants et cetera donc
mes chers collègues si je suis
aujourd'hui
ardemment partisan de ce changement dans
les murs de la politique française c'est
parce que comme vous j'ai vécu un
certain nombre de circonstances et je
voulais vous dire que je suis
persuadé que si nous faisons cette
réforme si nous la soutenons et bien
nous changerons la manière dont on fait
de la politique dans ce pays et que
c'est vraiment que c'est vraiment
nécessaire je mais je vous dis ma
conviction vous direz la vôtre tout à
l'heure on est là pour se parler
deuxièmement
non mais écoutez chacun s'exprime comme
il le veut et on a le droit deire par de
parler de la réalité mes chers collègues
et même de la réalité
vécue deuxème point nous avons écouté
les
constitutionnalistes et je veux
reprendre un argument qui a déjà été
évoqué par Manuel Vals et par Simon
sutau si on insiste tellement sur le
fait qu'en vertu de l'article 24 de la
constition que je ne conteste pas les
encore heureux le Sénat représente les
assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
République il y a quand même le risque
qu'on nous dise un jour et et cela a été
dit et non pas par les moindres des
personnes qui s'occupent de ces sujets
on nous dira un jour et bien très bien
le Sénat il est tout à fait pertinent
pour s'occuper des lois qui traitent des
communes départements et régions et on
aura la situation qui existe dans
d'autres pays on a cité monsieur le
ministre la situation de l'Allemagne on
aura une chambre qui aura les pouvoirs
sur tous les domaines et une autre qui
ne serait consulté que s'agissant des
collectivités locales et bien je dis que
cela cette orientation là serait une
profonde erreur et je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que je pense et nous
sommes nombreux je le sais à penser
qu'il est extrêmement précieux pour la
République que les deux assemblées du
Parlement traite de tous les sujets nous
sommes parfaitement légitimes pour
parler de la défense pour parler de la
Justice de la santé de la sécurité de
tous les domaines autant que les députés
même si les députés ont le dernier mot
en vertu de notre
Constitution et c'est très important
parce que si on avait une chambre qui ne
s'occupait que des collectivités locales
cela aurait pour conséquence inéluable
qu'il n'y aurait plus de navette il y
aurait une Assemblée nationale qui
traiterait de tout
or or
oui mais ça là-dessus mes chers
collègues nous sommes nombreux à le
regretter et nous voyons l'avantage
qu'il y a quand il y a des navettes on
l'a encore vu ce matin avec la loi sur
les métropoles on a eu un excellent
débat en commission des lois qui va
continuer parce que la loi finalement
elle est le fruit de discussions de
débats qui sont parfois vifs dans les
assemblées mais à partir de cela il faut
faire une norme et pour passer du
discursif au normatif pour faire la
norme il faut du temps un peu comme la
mère poli le galet il faut que les
textes passent et repassent entre les
deux assemblées de manière à ce qu'il
soit peu à peu les meilleurs possibles
les mieux écrits possibles et mes chers
collègues il y a des lois qui ne sont
pas toujours bien écrites et c'est
pourquoi il est très important de ne pas
s'orienter vers un sénat qui ne serait
concerné que par les textes concernant
les collectivités
territoriales je voulais dire enfin
que il y a quand même une réalité
matérielle lundi nous étions là je dis
nous pour parler d'une importante loi
sur l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes bien merci à ceux à celles et à
ceux qui étaient là et oui vous avez
raison Madame Assassi
et regardons les choses en face si l'on
veut traiter de tous les textes qui nous
sont soumis et bien entendu même si on
se limite au texte qui concerne la
commission à laquelle on appartient si
l'on veut exercer la mission de contrôle
rester en contact bien sûr avec les
électeurs et les habitants du
département qui nous a élu c'est quelque
chose qui prend à temps plein moi je
j'en ai la la conviction pour avoir vécu
cela depuis déjà tro décennies et j'en
ai vraiment la
conviction vraiment la conviction on a
mon cher
collègue on a tellement de talent en
France tellement de personnes
compétentes et dévouées que je vois pas
pourquoi finalement la même personne
doit exercer deux fonctions qui pourrai
être exercé par deux personnes
différentes
enfin je dirais que le Sénat de la
République non seulement monsieur le
Président du Sénat depuis l'alternance
qui a eu lieu il y a 2 ans mais même
auparavant par rapport à un certain
nombre de sujets à suêtre re
progressiste et il y a bien des sujets
je parlais de la
décentralisation regardez la dernière
loi de
décentralisation comment elle est
arrivée comment elle est repartie du
Sénat elle a quand même été votée par
180 d'entre nous donc par une large
majorité dans ce domaine comme dans
beaucoup de domaines le Sénat a été
progressiste et il a été peut-être
davantage que l'Assemblée nationale dans
un certain nombre de domaines que chacun
ici connaît bien et bien je vous diraiis
que j'ai la crainte qu'une
crispation sur cette question du cumul
le fait que nous nous
cramponnons aux pratiques du
passé redonne au Sénat cette image
conservatrice que nous avons beaucoup
combattu alors que j'aime beaucoup le
Sénat lorsqu'il prend le risque et qu'il
saisit la chance d'être le Sénat du
progrès je vous
remercie merci monsieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues je suis
particulièrement heureux de saluer en
votre nom la présence dans notre tribune
d'honneur d'une délégation du
Guatemala
conduite conduite par son ministre de
l'Économie monsieur Sergio de la tauré
accompagné notamment par Monsieur
Emmanuel sedner député vice-président de
la commission des relation extérieure du
congrès du Guatemala cette délégation a
rencontré des membres du groupe d'amitié
Fran
Mexique et pays d'Amérique centrale
notamment monsieur Gérard Cornu
président de ce groupe et Monsieur
Gérard Mel président délégué pour
l'Amérique
centrale nous formons le vœ que cette
visite soit profitable à nos amis
guatémalteèques et conforte l'excellence
de nos relations entre nos deux pays
nous les nous leur souhaitons la plus
cordiale bienvenue au Sénat français je
vous
remercie
mes chers collègues il est 15h30 à peu
près 35 je déclare clos les scrutins
pour l'élection de membre titulaire et
de membre suppléent représentant la
France à l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de
l'Europe dans la suite de la discussion
générale commune la parole est à madame
la Présidente Ilian
assass
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues comme l'a
souligné la commission de rénovation et
de déontologie de la vie publique dirigé
par Lionel
Jospin le cumul des mandats est un sujet
essentiel pour l'avenir des institutions
de nos
institutions il aurait de ce fait mérité
un projet de loi plus
ambitieux que celui qui va nous occuper
certes mon groupe soutiendra ce texte
car bien qu'il soit incomplet il
s'inscrit dans l'exigence démocratique
de la vie politique que nous avons
toujours soutenu et affirmé autant que
possible en 2008 par exemple lors du
débat parlementaire sur la réforme
constitutionnelle nous avions proposé un
amendement visant à inscrire dans la
Constitution le principe de limitation
du cumule des mandats électoraux la
majorité d'alors avait rejeté cet
amendement qui prenait pourtant une
proposition émise par le comité baladure
mais si nous soutenons la limitation du
cumul des mandats nous considérons que
des objectifs plus ambitieux sont
indispensables pour répondre aux enjeux
démocratiques de première import
que les lacunes de nos institutions
posent
aujourd'hui j'y reviendrai mais je
voudrais dans un premier temps m'arrêter
sur quelques
aspects des él qui ne souscrivent pas ce
texte
avance l'argument d'un nécessaire
ancrage local des élus nationaux ils
craignent que la prohibition du cumul
transforme les députés les sénateurs en
professionnels du Parlement
moins capable en quelque sorte de
représenter leurs électeurs ils
craignent en résumé que les
parlementaires soient coupés des
réalités de la vie locale et je dois
dire que ce serait effectivement
dommageable s'ils ont néanmoins raison
de se soucier du maintien d'un rapport
régulier entre les parlementaires et les
électeurs je pense pour ma part qu'il
faut aller encore plus loin en inventant
des formes nouvelles d'immersion dans la
vie locale en associant la popul au
choix qui la concerne car la limitation
du cumul des mandats ne peut se
concevoir sans développement de la
démocratie
participative pourquoi ne pas prévoir
par exemple l'obligation pour les
parlementaire de venir présenter les
projets lois dans leur circonscription
et d'en débattre avec les
citoyens pourquoi ne pas instaurer des
conseils de
circonscription pourquoi ne pas prévoir
que nos concitoyens puissent intervenir
auprès de leurs représentants pour
obliger le Parlement à examiner une
proposition de loi émanant d'un nombre
signific significatif d'électeurs et ce
ne sont là que quelques idées parmi
d'autres ne l'oublions pas le vote de la
loi n'appartient qu'au peuple tout
entier soit par référendum soit par ses
représentants au Parlement les décisions
doivent donc être prises autrement la
souveraineté populaire doit cesser
d'être confisquée il est urgent de
redonner ce pouvoir à nos concitoyens si
nous ne voulons pas voir perdurer la
grave crise de la représentation
politique que nous connaissons
actuellement alors certes cette crise du
politique vient
essentiellement de la prise de pouvoir
de l'économie sur la politique sur le
politique mais limiter le cumul des
mandats c'est aussi donner le pouvoir
aux parlementaires de pleinement remplir
leur mission et soyons francs le manque
de temps la précipitation la surcharge
renforce également considérablement le
pouvoir des lobby expression concrète du
pouvoir économique certains opposants au
N cumulent des mandats agitent aussi le
chiffon de la montée du Front
national je ne cesse de le
répéter le front nation
ce combat d'abord et avant tout sur le
terrain des idées pour claquer la porte
au nez des idéologies à Roland nasé à
bond il faut savoir
rassurer répondre du courage aussi tout
le monde n a pas donc il faut rassurer
répondre échanger avec la population
afin d'atténuer les craintes d'une
dégradation économique de notre pays
mais en aucun cas le Front national ne
doit servir de prétexte ce serait
d'ailleurs de lui donner de l'importance
ne doit servir de
prétexte pour fermer la porte au débat
institutionnel et la nécessaire
évolution de nos institution aucun des
arguments avancés en la matière n'est
donc convaincant et je le répète c'est
malheureusement le contraire qui se
passe et nous le voyons aujourd'hui je
vous parlais il y a quelques an de la
nécessité de réfléchir aux enjeux
démocratiques de première importance mis
à mal par la crise de la
représentation je vous disais donc que
les solutions que nous devons lui
apporter dépassent largement la question
de la limitation du cumu des mandats en
effet en arrière-plan du cumul des
mandats se
pose surtout des questions relatives à
la professionnalisation de la politique
de la concentration des pouvoirs tant
politique économique d'ailleurs entre
les mains d'un petit nombre du
décaisissement de la souveraineté
populaire là sont les réels enjeux
démocratiques si on veut que le lien
soit rétabli entre le peuple et ses
institutions national il faudra alors
bien plus qu'une simple interdiction du
cumul des mandats tout ce qui entrave
l'expression démocratique de la
souveraineté populaire doit être
aujourd'hui déconstruit les modes
élection les pouvoirs doivent être
réévalués à la mesure de la crise de la
représentation actuelle ainsi et c'est
un point crucial pour nous je sais bien
que tout le monde ici ne le partage pas
et loin de là ce point crucial c'est le
scrutin proportionnel qui doit selon
nous devenir la règle le mode de scrutin
nominal à de Tours ça sert à rien quand
ça ne vous arrange pas le mode de
scrutin nominale à de Tours tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui pour l'élection vous
n'avez pas entendu ce que je vous ai dit
précédemment ça se combat sur le terrain
des idées le Front national le mode
alors en ce moment vous n'y contribuez
pas excusez-moi le mode de scrutin
nominal à de Tours tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui pour l'élection des députés
des conseillers généraux et de la moitié
des sénateurs favorise consensus
politique personnalisation durée et
cumule des mandats donc
professionnalisation de la politique on
ne cesse de le dire pas plus tard
qu'hier lors de la discussion du projet
de loi relatif à l'égalité des hommes et
des femmes où il y avait d'ailleurs peu
d'hommes parlementaires je suppose
qu'ils étaient pris par ailleurs le
scrutin proportionnel et le seul qui
permet l'égal accès aux femmes et aux
hommes au mandat électif on constate que
parmi les élus ce sont les hommes qui
cumulent le plus et qui effectuent le
plus grand nombre de mandats
successifs cette situation fait barrage
aux femmes mais également aux jeunes et
à la diversité sociale et d'origine
comment nos concitoyens ne se sentiraent
pas mal représentés pour le moins quand
dans sa composition le Parlement n'est
réellement plus représentatif de la
société telle qu'elle est au Parlement
les ouvriers par exemple se compte sur
les doigts d'une main les parlementaires
sont de plus en plus âgés la moyenne
d'âge en tout cas à l'Assemblée
nationale n'a cessé de croître depuis la
Libération on est en 2013 si vous voyez
ce que je veis dire limiter ou interdire
le cumul des mandats sans instaurer la
proportionnelle laissera toute réforme
progressiste de nos institutions au
milieu du gay autre point c'est celui de
la reproduction des élites c'est un
problème je dirais même que c'est un
problème majeur de notre démocratie et
pour ma part je pense qu'ils sont trop
nombreux quelquefois trop nombreuses
mais moins qui sortent des mêmes écoles
ont suivi les mêmes
cursus cette professionnalisation de la
politique est flagrante à l'échelle
nationale mais aussi dans les
territoires la décentralisation a donné
des pouvoirs importants aux exécutifs
locaux dans une très grande proximité
avec les décideurs économiques qui font
l'emploi certains maires de ville de
grosses agglomérations sont président
d'une importante intercommunalité
d'autres sont Présidents du Conseil
général ou régional les mandats électifs
sont en outre souvent assortis de
responsabilités locales diverses
présidence des conseils d'administration
société d'économie mixte et cetera et
cetera et ils peuvent rester longtemps
en place puisque le renouvellement des
mandats n'est pas limité et que le mode
de scrutin favorise le localisme il est
clair dans ces conditions que leur ris
local souvent assorti du cumul avec un
mandat national crée de véritable
féodalité par rapport au pouvoir central
censé assurer l'égalité des citoyens et
des territoires mais allons plus loin
encore à côté d'une Assemblée nationale
élue à la proportionnelle le Sénat
n'aurait-il pas un rôle fondamental à
jouer dans la mise en place d'une
meilleure représentation et une
meilleure participation des citoyens
dans la diversité de leur implication
décision la deuxème assemblée pourrait
à la fois la représentation territoriale
et la représentation sociale dont on
parle peu elle pourrait être composé par
exemple pour moitié de représentants des
collectivités locales élu au suffrage
universel direct sur liste
départementale de candidat ayant une
expérience élective dans une
collectivité puis l'autre moitié serait
quant à elle composé de représentants de
groupes sociaux élus de la même façon
alors que les choses soient claires
nous sommes pour le bicamérisme mais un
bicamérisme utile dès lors qu'il permet
d'améliorer la qualité de la loi et que
comme je l'ai dit qu'il conduise à une
meilleure participation des citoyens
dans la diversité de leur implication
aux décision encore un point crucial qui
manque à cette réforme pour que la
politique cesse donc d'être une
profession et devienne une activité
sociale courante pour un nombre plus ant
de citoyens qui pourrai par exemple
pendant une période de leur vie exercer
des mandats électifs un statut
protecteur qui leur permettent de
revenir à leur emploi intérieur ou
d'accéder à une formation débouchant sur
un un nouvel emploi est primordial oui
notre démocratie a besoin d'un véritable
statut de l'élu qui ne se limite pas à
des seuls aspects financiers par
exemple
c'est aussi de revenir sur la réforme du
quinena et l'inversion du calendrier
électoral qui entre autres a mise en
place un président c'estàdire une
personne qui détient d'énormes pouvoirs
ce qui peut favoriser des dérives qui
peut faire beaucoup de mal à notre
démocratie alors je finirai sur un
dernier
point le cumul des mandats
concerne tous les partis politiques sans
exception ce qui veut dire pour être
clair que le mien n'y échappe pas il est
la résultante d'un système
institutionnel qui dessert le pluralisme
et il est difficile d'y échapper oui
c'est difficile même quand on le combat
on entend ici et là que nous aurions
beaucoup à perdre nous par par exemple
les élus
communistes
mais je dois dire que nous sommes pas
les seul non mais excusez-moi mais vos
petites remarques qui ne valent pas un
sou
voulez quand on vous parle de démocratie
et de valeurs je vois bien que ça vous
dérange un peu mais voyez-vous nous
avons pour notre part effectivement un
certain nombre de
principes et un certain nombre valeur
auquell nous sommes très attachés et peu
importe et peu importe peu importe si la
proportionnelle ne nous renforce pas peu
importe si le sujet du cumulle des
mandats ne nous rapporte pas comme
disent certains ce n'est pas là le
problème j'ai des valeurs j'ai des
principes j'y tiens je me bats pour elle
il y en a d'autres ici et c'est tant
mieux
vous le voyez donc mon soutien à ce
enfin notre soutien je ne parlerai pas
en mon nom personnel notre soutien à ce
projet de loi n'est pas qu'un simple
soutien à une promesse de campagne qui
trouve aujourd'hui sa concrétisation il
se fonde et je voudrais insister sur une
conviction profonde l'urgence vraiment
l'urgence d'une démocratisation de la
vie politique et ce dans tous ces
aspects je vous
remercie merci la parole au président
François queto pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lorsqu'il
est question de réformer nos
institutions les maîtres mot inspirant
nos travaux devrai être la Concorde la
confiance et la prudence malheureusement
je ne peux pas démarrer mon propos sans
évoquer les conditions déplorables dans
lesquelles cette réforme est examinée
par le Sénat depuis la première réunion
de la Conférence des Présidents où ce
sujet a été abordé nous n'avons cessé
avec d'autres présidents de groupe je
pense en particulier à Jacques mzar mais
il n'y a pas que lui de dénoncer un
travail parlementaire réalisé à la hache
dont la seule finalité est d'arracher au
s un texte dont les enjeux ne sont pas
maîtrisés nous avons tout fait
croyez-nous pour tenter de rectifier le
tir mais il n'y avait rien à faire c'est
d'autant plus surprenant de mépriser à
ce point le Parlement lorsqu'il s'agit
de transformer les conditions mêmes de
l'exercice du mandat parlementaire ces
mauvaises conditions que nous dénonçons
c'est bien sûr tout d'abord le recours à
la procédure accélérée pour un texte qui
a vocation à entrer en vigueur pardon de
le rappeler mais en
2017 serait-elle là l'urgence pour le
gouvernement ne serait-elle pas dans la
désindustrialisation qui la mine notre
économie ou encore dans la lutte contre
le chômage ou encore dans l'insécurité
qui mine notre Pact
social en réalité cette procédure
accélérée n'a qu'un seul objectif brider
le Parlement brimer le Sénat limiter au
maximum le travail qui pourrait
ressortir de notre assemblée car le
gouvernement a compris pris depuis
longtemps que le Sénat serait plutôt
rétisent pour ne pas dire rétif à ces
propositions et qui valait mieux ne pas
laisser le Sénat s'exprimer trop
longtemps la méthode est vraiment claire
depuis le début vite vite vite allons au
dernier mot à l'Assemblée nationale pour
que les les députés puissent adopter le
texte qu'ils ont voté le 9 juillet
dernier il s'était pardon d'ailleurs
empressé d'annoncer que dès cette date
j'en cite un certain nombre ça y est ça
y est la réforme du non cumule de le
mandat a été adopté et vos propos à
cette tribune tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre allai exactement dans le même
sens puisque vous nous avez dit pour
parler clairement circuler il y a rien à
voir c'est déjà
décidé je me tourne maintenant vers mes
collègues de la commission des lois mes
éminents collègues le président et le
rapporteur pour leur dire que ils
doivent convenir que la préparation du
rapport a aussi été pardon mais tout
aussi expéditive
ceux qui ne font pas partie de cette
commission pourront être intéressés de
savoir que la désignation du rapporteur
le dernier jour de la précédente session
pour un examen du rapport au tout début
de la nouvelle session n'a permis que
quelques auditions un lundi ou un mardi
après-midi et un rapport prêt pour sa
présentation devant la commission dès le
lendemain matin bravo monsieur le
rapporteur nous connaissions votre
grande qualité mais là c'est vraiment
tous les records sont
bâtimés
je passe aussi sur le fait mais je le
cite quand même que l'article 46 de la
Constitution dit les lois organiques
relatives au Sénat doivent être voté
dans les mêmes dans les mêmes termes par
les deux assemblée alors je ne me
lancerai pas dans une exégèse des
dernières jurisprudences du Conseil
constitutionnel mais il y a matière
néanmoins à réfléchir car certes il n'y
a qu'une seule loi organique là dans le
texte qui nous est présenté mais euh ne
devriayons-nous pas procéder autrement
et le Conseil constitutionnel ne peut-il
pas analyser ce texte comme étant deux
euh texte de loi organique c'est lui qui
le dira s'il est saisi tout cela bien
sûr n'est pas du tout sérieux et dégrade
l'image du Parlement et celle du Sénat
alors que ce sujet est essentiel pour
l'avenir de nos institutions et du
Parlement en particulier il est et je le
dis je pèse mes mots il est scandaleux
que le débat soit aussi contraint alors
qu'on fond rien imposait une telle
urgence les sénateurs de notre groupe
estiment qu'une réflexion complète sur
la question du cumul ne peut bien sûr
pas se limiter à la question du cumul
applicable au parlementairirees il est
impératif d'étudier le régime applicable
entre les mandats locaux c'est pas la
première fois que nous faisons cette
remarque ce fameux cumul horizontal cher
notamment à Madame Martine Aubri doit
être revu or ce thème n'est absolument
pas abordé dans le texte que vous nous
présenter monsieur le ministre si l'on
regarde vos arguments ils sont en
réalité assez limités puisque le
principal argument c'est celui d'une
prétendue modernité du système que vous
nous proposez par opposition bien sûr au
droits positif actuel qui serait donc
dépassé et vous ne craignez pas de dire
ringard vous vous l'avez répété à mainre
reprise monsieur le ministre il ne faut
pas rater le train de la
modernité convenez que cet argument est
bien faible et je ne suis pas sûr qu'au
fond de vous-même vous en soyez
convaincus car il sous-entendraiit que
le système actuel n'est pas
démocratique il semblerait aussi que
certains d'entre vous n'ayez pas compris
la spécificité de la 5e République car
dès lors que l'État est omniprésent
omnipotent dès lors que tous les leviers
de commandement sont concentrés dans les
mains de l'exécutif et bien il n'était
pas étonnant que la première tentative
de rééquilibrage des institution a été
pour les parlementaires de s'affranchir
de la main mise du gouvernement avec le
soutien et la connaissance des réalités
du terrain et d'ailleurs vousmême
monsieur le ministre et vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure vous vous en êtes
bien rendu compte puisque ce n'est pas
une critique mais un simple rappel il
n'y a pas si longtemps vous étiez député
de la première circonscription de les
son maire d' président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération
d'evon pour ne citer que ses fonctions
il est vrai que depuis vous êtes passé
de l'autre côté du côté de l'omnipotence
du pouvoir
exécutif on peut légitimement opposer la
question du cumul ou du non cumul de
mandat mais c'est un faux débat de faire
croire que d'un côté il y aurait par
nature un système qui serait supérieur à
l'autre surtout lorsqu'on le déconnecte
de la réalité
institutionnelle car les choix que vous
proposez auront des conséquences
institutionnelles fortes personne ne
sait dans quelle mesure le travail
parlementaire sera soutenable avec des
assemblées composées d'élus horsol vous
n'aimez pas qu'on utilise le terme mais
ce sera la vérité et il n'y a aucune
corrélation aujourd'hui il suffit de
regarder les statistiques entre le fait
d'être un parlementaire cumulant et le
fait d'être un bon parlementaire il y a
tous les cas de figure et c'est
d'ailleurs cette diversité qui enrichit
la réflexion
démocratique aucune réflexion n'a donc
été menée quant à l'évolution des
prérogatives et des méthodes du travail
parlementaire après une telle réforme
les parlementaires auront-ils des moyens
de contrôle mis à leur disposition plus
importants que ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui ce qui voudrait dire que à
coup budgétaire constant il faudrait
diminuer le nombre de parlementaires
nous attendons les explications du
Gouvernement sur ce sujet nous n'avons
rien entendu pour l'instant l'autre
grand argument que vous invoquez c'est
que dans les démocraties occidentales il
n'y aurait pas de cumul permettez-moi de
vous rappeler d'ailleurs le rapporteur
l'a dit honnêtement tout à l'heure dans
beaucoup de pays je crois même que dans
une majorité de pays qui fonctionne
comme le nôtre le cumul de mandat n'est
pas interdit simplement il n'est pas
pratiqué ou il est pratiqué par une
minorité de parlementaires et bien
pourquoi vous le savez très bien c'est
que l'organisation des pouvoirs
publicque dans un pays comme la France
n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'elle est dans
d'autres pays comme l'Allemagne ou même
l'Italie pour ne parler que de deux de
nos voisins nous avons cette tradition
du centralisme français qui n'existe pas
dans les pays dans lesquels curieusement
il n'y a pas de cumul de mandat le
statut de l'élu a été évoqué c'est un
serpent de mer qui revient toujours mais
on ne peut pas parler du cumul de mandat
sans parler du statut de
l'élu le débat qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui
est aussi en figrane un débat sur la
décentralisation ou plus exactement sur
la relation entre nos territoires nos
collectivités et le pouvoir central
n'ayons pas peur de le dire notre pays
n'est pas un pays réellement
décentralisé ch c'est bien et c'est bien
parce que la majorité des décisions
politiques sont prises à Paris que les
élus locaux toute tendance politique
confondue il y a aucune différence de ce
point de vue-là ces élus locaux ont
depuis longtemps compris l'importance de
détenir un mandat parlementaire qui les
rapproche des vrais lieux de pouvoir et
qui accroit leur efficacité sinon
comment seraitt-il élu et réélu si
souvent on ne peut donc faire à ce
moment l'économie d'une réflexion sur
l'équilibre des pouvoirs au sein de
notre démocratie dans notre régime hyper
présidentialisé la présence de
responsables d'exécutifs locaux au
Parlement contribue à cet équilibre et
en résumé sur ce point je voudrais citer
des auteurs universitaires qui disent
très bien l'exception française du cumul
des mandats est donc une réponse
imparfaite certes mais un incontestable
contrepoids à l'exception française du
cumul des pouvoirs de la concentration
extrême des pouvoirs entre les mains du
Président de la République il ne faut
donc pas interdire le cumul des mandats
sans rééquilibrer nos
institutions autrement dit il y a là une
vraie question préjudicielle à la
question du cumul des mandats vous ne
pouvez pas supprimer le cumul des
mandats si vous maintenez le système
institutionnel actuel car vous allez
forcément aboutir à un renforcement de
la tout puissance présidentielle je
évidemment nous ne pourrions pas mieux
dire que ces auteurs très
inspirés au-delà de notre groupe le
Sénat est prêt à débattre de la question
du cumul et d'ailleurs il l'a fait déjà
à de nombreuses reprise car nous savons
bien que c'est l'avenir du Parlement
c'est l'avenir de notre assemblée qui
sont en jeu et je crois que votre projet
monsieur le ministre n'est qu'une simple
mise à jour qui en fait ne va pas loin
dans l'étude des problèmes que quel
Sénat voulons-nous pour demain quel
Sénat est-ce que nous voulons un sénat
monolitique composé de retraités
efficaces compétent certes mais
retraités de fonctionnaires tout aussi
efficaces mais très nombreux et je redis
le terme que vous n'aimez pas d'apparat
chic de partis politiqu et croyez-moi
chers collègues si vous votez cette
réforme nous irons plus vite que vous le
croyez vers cette forme de Parlement il
n'y a qu'à voir le résultat des
dernières élections législatives
50 % des nouveaux députés sont des
permanentes partis politiques ou des
membres de cabinet politique voilà voilà
la vérité on peut la
vérifier nous n'acceptons pas cette
dérive vers un parlement monolitique et
aussi peu représentatif des Français
alors nous nous faisons des propositions
pour que notre Sénat soit un sénat qui
soit comme celui qui avait eu la force
de opposé au général de Gaulle comme à
l'époque de Gaston monerville est-ce
aussi le Sénat de demain qui aurait su
dire non à un ministre de l'Intérieur
lorsqu'il souhaitait développer les
tests ADN des contrôles migratoires je
me tourne vers vous à gauche est-ce que
le Sénat de demain sera celui qui sera
dire non à la déchéance de nationalité
est-ce que le Sénat de demain sera
s'opposer à l'incurie budgettaire qui
semble avaler sans trop de difficultés
par l'Assemblée nationale qui qui est
issue de la majorité présidentielle donc
qui est sous la dépendance du Président
vous savez notre vision du Sénat n'est
pas la vôtre nous voulons un sénat
indépendant nous voulons un sénat qui ne
soit pas sous la tutelle de partis
politique nous voulons un sénat qui
continue à représenter les collectivités
territoriales de la République voilà les
propositions que nous ferons et qui
seront détaillées par certains de nos
collègues car nous allons proposer avec
un certain nombre de collègues texte
nous ne disons pas non à la réforme du
cumul des mandats mais nous allons
proposer notre réforme et nous demandons
au sénateurs de voter cette réforme de
façon à ce que la voix du Sénat soit
entendue qu'elle prospère et qu'elle
gagne si possible je vous remercie merci
la parole est à présent à monsieur le
Président Jacques mzard pour le groupe
RDS
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues vous
comprendrez que c'est avec émotion que
je m'adresse ce jour à vous sénateur et
sénatrices et sénateurs en qualité de
président du groupe héritier de celui de
la gauche démocratique d'un groupe qui
se confond avec la vie du Sénat celle de
la République de ses valeurs fondatrices
valeur dont l'actualité démontre tous
les jours qu'elles n'ont pas pris une
ride aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le combat
gauche- droite ni celui de la modernité
c'est celui de la
République aussi c'est l'expression d'un
groupe unanime que je vous transmets à
cette
tribune je pense à ceux qui nous ont
précéd dans cet hémicycle à ceux qui ont
fait la République à ceux aussi qui se
sont en batttu pour que le Sénat apporte
à la République l'équilibre et la
réflexion marque du bicamérisme et
comment ne pas citer Gaston monerville
lui qui pendant 22 ans par sa présidence
courageuse a restauré le Sénat a
préservé son indépendance et son
existence lui qui a eu le courage et
l'audace de démissionner de la
présidence du Sénat dans un discours que
je vous invite chaque à lire ou à relire
et ce pour aller soutenir le débat
devant le pays plus qu'un exemple un
modèle il nous manque lui le premier
président de gauche du Sénat de la 5e
République aussi c'est avec la profonde
humilité d'un sénateur qui ne dispose
d'aucune notoriété nationale d'aucun
relais médiatique que je vous parle mais
je le fais avec toute ma conviction ma
fidélité je sais où je suis monsieur
monsieur le ministre et j'y resterai
malgré toutes les insinuations oui je
crois encore qu'on peut siéger à gauche
et rester
libre c'est pour cela que de tout mon
être mes chers collègues je vous dis que
le projet du gouvernement est une
atteinte grave à nos institutions que je
vous dis du fond de ce qui met le plus
cher qu'il faut le combattre et le
rejeter Bou par ce texte sont
considérables dévastateurs pour la
démocratie parlementaire et l'équilibre
de nos institutions plus qu'un
bouleversement c'est une révolution ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est vous
monsieur le ministre à la page 52 du
rapport je vous cite je ne sous-estime
pas l'ampleur de ce changement qui est
une véritable révolution et bien une
révolution on ne doit pas la faire à la
sauvette par une procédure accélérée en
session extraordinaire haché par les
congés d'été comme des braconniers
législatifs
qui font leur coup nuitamment le visage
masqué par la cagoule de la
modernisation de la vie
publique monsieur le ministre pas vous
pas ça vous savez l'estime que nous
avons pour vous pour vos propos souvent
à la marge de votre appartenance
partisane mes chers collègues je me dois
de vous donner lecture d'un passage d'un
excellent livre écrit en 2008 son titre
pour en finir avec le vieux socialisme
et être ENF de gauche en le lisant je
m'étais dit nous voilà sauveré c'est
l'avenir page 14 je cite une chose
m'amuse avec le nombre de députés maires
que nous avons eu au PS on va enterrer
cette idée somptueusement fausse de
l'interdiction du cumul des
mandats page
15 répondante à la question mais le nom
cumule était au cœur de la Nouvelle
Démocratie réponse je l'ai même écrit
j'y croyais et j'ai eu tort c'était une
diversion ça fait partie des histoires
qu'on se raconte pour s'étournir quand
on a perdu son
identité je pourrais continuer mais vous
le savez par
cœur vous aurez vous aurez mes chers
collègues tous reconnus l'auteur de ces
lignes il est en face de moi il est
devenu depuis notre ministre de
l'Intérieur je pourrais arrêtez là mon
propos moi qui vous ai fait confiance
avec beaucoup d'autres moi qui dit
depuis des mois que ce projet de loi est
une imposture et bien en fait il suffit
de vous lire pour le
prouver qui est enfin de gauche
aujourd'hui vous nous vous voulez une
majorité rose verte je ne voudrais pas
que vous récoltiez demain une majorité
bleu sombre monsieur le ministre il
n'est pas si loin le temps où vous
concluiez le même
ouvrage par ces mots j'ai mis du temps à
admettre que j'aurais plus facilement
applaudi le tigre que le fondateur de
l'humanité maintenant
j'assume vous pensez bien que nous y
sommes sensibles à ces propos monsieur
le ministre clémenenceau n'a jamais été
socialiste parce que c'est lui qui
disait qu'au premier souffle de la
réalité le palais de féerie s'envole
parce que c'est à lui qu'en novembre
1917 une grande majorité de socialiste
au cœur de la tourmente a refusé la
confiance gravir les marches qui mènent
au pouvoir suprême nécessite bien des
renoncements voire des contradictions
nous le comprenons la politique est
humaine donc dur sans pitié rares sont
ceux qui n'en arrivent pas à marcher sur
leurs propres amis mais monsieur le
ministre au moment où vous acceptez de
porter ce texte manifestement contraire
à ce que vous avez exprimé il y a peu
texte dont les effets seront négatifs
pour toutes les familles politiques
minoritaires en premier lieu la nôtre il
ne serait pas pas très convenable
qu'après avoir provoqué le décès
électoral de nombre de nos élus vous
vous rendiez aussi coupable de la
captation de l'héritage de clémenenceau
lequel avait en outre un profond respect
du
Parlement beaucoup de socialistes
témoigne leur fidélité à l'action de
François mitteran nous aussi non
seulement parce que sénateur il siégea
au sein de notre groupe mais parce qu'il
a marqué par sa stature d'homme d'État
notre pays souvent contre l'opinion
publique comme il le fit en abolissant
la peine de mort pouvez-vous
imaginer une seule seconde mes chers
collègues qu'un de ses ministres est osé
proposer le binôme départemental où le
non cumule des
mandats il déclara il déclarait la
disparition de tout cumul serait un
moyen détourné pour le pouvoir central
de renforcer son autorité nous
partageons encore totalement son analyse
alors
alors pourquoi cet acharnement à faire
passer ce texte en force contre la
volonté du Sénat et avec une procédure
bâlé est-ce le texte fondateur du
quinquena attendu par les Français alors
qu'ils sont tous les jours préoccupés
légitimement par l'emploi l'économie la
fiscalité la sécurité l'Europe la crise
syrienne d'où vient réellement cette
imposture que sont la campagne anti-élu
et le projet
antiumule nous le savons tous
de la prise de contrôle de votre parti
par Madame auri car c'était le moyen
privilégié et le plus facile d'agréger
les militants puis de négocier des
primaires
présidentielles le tout accompagné d'une
longue et puissante opération médiatique
en particulier de la presse boboste
parisienne après le monde libération le
point d'org en fut voici quelques jours
L'Express à point nommé et bien oui moi
j'ai mal j'ai mal quand je lis quand
j'entends présenter notre collègue
deulbar pour qui j'ai le plus profond
respect comme le premier cumular de
France c'est ça le résultat de votre
action depuis des
mois et je ne citerai pas le trème or
l'essence même du responsable politique
c'est d'avoir le courage de braver
l'opinion de ne pas s'y soumettre
aveuglément de juin 40 à l'abolition de
la
et de tant d'autres exemples au-delà du
contenu du texte je tiens à
exprimer notre indignation concernant
les méthodes qui ont été utilisées pour
carur caricaturer notre opposition et
dévoyer la procédure parlementaire vous
vous indignez tout à l'heure que nous
utilisions le mot aparik et vous nous
faites califier depuis des mois de
cumular à longueur de journée il est
insupportable que comme pour le texte
transparence le gouvernement soit
complice d'une campagne médiatique
cultivant un antiparlementarisme injuste
et
dévastateur il n'est pas raisonnable il
n'est pas
raisonnable que soit jeté en pâure aux
médias et à l'opinion des dizaines de
milliers d'élus dont l'immense majorité
accomplit sa mission avec conscience et
honnêteté pire nous n'avons pas à nous
repentir à votre place des Herms de
Monsieur kahusac depuis des
mois vous clouez au pilori des milliers
d'élus vitupérés dans les médias comme
cumularard sous-entendu goin fris de
privilège et d'indemnité c'est
particulièrement déshonorant d'utiliser
ces méthodes je devais le dire ici à
cette
tribune
deè deè procédé déplorable la procédure
législative utilisé qui a pour
conséquence un débat tronqué le Sénat de
la République a été mis devant le fait
accompli et je le regrette sans réaction
forte de son exécutif tout d'abord il
n'est pas acceptable que sur un tel
projet de loi à effet 2017 la procédure
accélérée est été
utilisée interdisant de fait tout
dialogue avec l'Assemblée nationale et
cela sans aucune explication ni aucune
justification du gouvernement le but est
clair trancher en évitant le débat et
faire décider par l'Assemblée nationale
au mépris de notre tradition
constitutionnelle des dispositions
relative à l'élection et au fonctionn du
Sénat de la République en contradiction
parfaite avec les dispositions de
l'article 24 et de l'article 46 de la
Constitution ce qui est en jeu mes chers
collègues c'est l'équilibre des
institutions de la République et le
principe même du
bicamérisme au vu d'un tel enjeu
l'utilisation de cette procédure
accélérée relève oui d'une véritable
provocation il en est de même quant au
calendrier que vous avez imposé
ainsi le rapporteur de ce texte a été
désigné par la commission des lois la
veille de la session extraordinaire le
24 juillet il a débuté ses auditions 9
septembre la veille de l'ouverture de la
nouvelle session les a clôturé le
lendemain la veille de la présentation
et de l'examen du rapport devant la
commission des lois qui d'ailleurs ne
l'a pas suivi et je ne doute pas qu'il
est mis à profit la nuit du 10 au 11
septembre triste jour pour méditer sur
nos excellentes propositions
il est vrai mais sais bien que ça ne
fait pas plaisir monsieur le président
de la commission des lois mais ça sera
quand même dit il est vrai il est vrai
je viens je viens à vous que vous avez
considéré vous président de la
commission des lois que cela n'avait pas
d'importance vous l'avez dit il n'en
reste pas moins qu'un tel mépris du
travail parlementaire est déplorable et
que lorsque vous siégiez dans
l'opposition vous l'auriez à juste titre
condamné
et monsieur le Président sueur sachez
que vous ne méritez en aucun cas notre
absolution vous ne respectez plus le
Parlement puisque ce sont là des
atteintes manifestes au droit du
Parlement et des parlementaires de la
même manière il est fallacieux et pour
nous insultant de nous faire passer et
en premier lieu notre groupe mais pas
seulement comme des ringards refusant
toute modernisation de la vie publique
il n'y a pas d'un côté les modernes et
de l'autre les archaïques non monsieur
le ministre nous sommes prêts tous ici à
ne pas rater ce que vous avez rappelé
appelé ce matin le train de l'histoire
mais ce n'est pas le même train le
nottre va bien plus loin sans démagogie
car la modernisation nos institutions
nous la préconisons depuis longtemps par
nos propositions de loi limitation du
cumul à un seul mandat exécutif pour les
parlementaires suppression de tout cumul
d'indemnité non ouvellement de certains
mandat limitation des cumules
horizontaux encadrement des
incompatibilités professionnelles
ringard cela lorsque vous vous proposez
beaucoup moins et que vous nous traitez
d'archaïque le texte en discussion est
une imposture oui il est destiné oui à
remplir les deux assemblées de militants
professionnels de la politique la
preuve
ce texte ce texte n'interdit le cumul
que pour les seuls parlementaires quand
madame auri pourra continuer à cumuler
la mairie de Lille la présidence de la
communauté urbaine et de multiples sèes
imposture aussi parce que le cumul reste
possible avec l'exercice de la plupart
des professions donc on a le temps
d'aller travailler ailleurs mais on n
pas le temps d'être maire d'une commune
de 30 habitants et
parlementaires
collègu il ne convient pas à de nouveaux
convertis de nous donner des leçons de
liturgie
oui de brûler ce que vous avez adoré du
président de la République au Premier
ministre j'ai consulter les CV des
principaux lodateurs du nom cumule c'est
accablant révélateur sur l'hypocrisie de
la nature humaine et l'amnésie de tant
d'entre eux et aussi pour certains de la
ranqueœur d'être débattu du suffrage
universelle monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous donnez
des leçons elles sont toujours
respectables car vous n'avez jamais eu
de mandat local mais
mais vous avez réussi l'exploit d'être
en même temps directeur général des
services du Département du gare et
sénateur
suppléant et ensuite vous êtes passé
directement de DGS de la ville de nî à
sénateur est-ce que vous avez pas eu le
sentiment d'une certaine rupture
d'égalité entre les
candidats je comprends mieux votre
opposition à nos amendements interdisant
de tels
exploits nos collègues
écologistes sont les élateurs de tel
texte dans l'opinion et plus encore dans
les médias et je respecte
profondément leurs opinions mais
sont-ils exemplaires je parle pas de
Monsieur ma mère je note que les trois
présidents et présidentes de groupes
parlementaires ont eu pour seule
activité avant leur mandat d'être
assistant
parlementaire j'ai les CV et puis
sont-ils tous les trois à l'image de
cette société française je note que
chacune ou chacun d'entre eux a un
conjoint élu parlementaire pour l'un
conseiller régional pour les autres
c'est un are cumul voilà ce qui nous
attend est-ce le
progrès monsieur le ministre vous
balayez nos arguments d' vers
demain non je vous dis simplement
monsieur le ministre que vous nous dites
circuler vous nous donnez des leçons à
tous depuis des mois et des
mois circuler non monsieur le ministre
parce que je vous respecte profondément
et je les respecte tous mais
respectez-nous aussi ce que vous n'avez
pas fait depuis des
mois vous nous dites circuler il n'y a
rien à voir je ne cèderai rien c'est
votre
droit vous nous dites le nom cumule
permettra au parlementaires d'être plus
présent dans les assemblées vous savez
pertinemment que c'est faux je vais pas
comparer mon travail parlementaire à
celui du rapporteur
citoyen. comom le fait bon ça suffira
j'en dirai pas
plus on nous dit je prendrai deux autres
exemples au Parlement européen deux élus
qui veulent se représenter et prendre le
nom cumu monsieur mon arlem désir et
Madame Eva jolie ils sont classés dans
les 30 derniers députés européens sur
plus de 750 et il cumulent
pas vos arguments ne tiennent pas et
vous le savez vous balayez avec mépris
toutes nos propositions vous ajoutez
aussi ce texte c'est aussi des élus
locaux à temps plein vous dites ce texte
c'est l'accession au responsabilités
d'une nouvelle génération avec des
profils et des origines différentes
ce matin dans la presse journaliste et
une parlementaire
disait le Sénat ce sont des hommes
blancs et bien moi quand j'entends ça je
frémis
oui c'est la confiscation du pouvoir par
des
apparatic qui pour la plupart n'ont
jamais exercé d'autres fonction et cela
cette nouvelle génération selon vous
nous n'en voulons pas et les Français et
tous les démocrates s'en repentiront ce
texte est une rupture une dénaturation
des institutions de la 5e République une
majorité d'universitaires parmi les plus
renommés le condamne que ce soit pierre
avril Dominique Rousseau Olivier be
Didier MOS pierre avril a condamné la
concentration du pouvoir entre les mains
du Président de la République qui s'est
selon lui traduite par une
caporalisation spécificité française il
dit la règle du non cumul les députés
d'une assise territoriale personnelle et
risque d'entraîner leur soumission aux
appareils partisans c'est vrai le
professeur beau il nous dit la lecture
du rapport de la commission Jospin
m'avait irrité par son dogmatisme et son
maniquéisme une telle réforme ne peut
qu'aggraver la la présidentialisation du
régime qu'accentuer la concentration des
pouvoirs cette réforme je le cite va
favoriser les apparat qui com comm leur
carrière à 20 ans dans les partis ce
déséquilibre des institutions cette
perversion de l'évolution de la 5e
République autour du Tout-Puissant
monarque républicain méritait un autre
débat que ce simulacre et j'en viens à
la dénaturation de l'esprit comme de la
lettre de la Constitution quant au
bicamérisme vous avez décidé d'affaiblir
le Sénat et de l'éteindre comme une
flamme qui finirait de se consumer le
nom cumule auquel vous ajoutez le Haut
Conseil des territoires c'est la fin de
la Haute Assemblée et la réduction du
nombre de sénateurs annoncé par le
président du Sénat c'est un duplicata de
l'Assemblée nationale autant dire la
vérité et supprimer le Sénat c'est
anomalie dénoncé par Monsieur Jospin
pourquoi n'assumez-vous pas vos
objectifs comme le fit loyalement à son
époque le général de Gaulle en
1969 c'était clair c'était loyal oui
l'article 24 de la Constitution dispose
que le Sénat assure la représentation
des collectivités territoriales de la
République c'est pour cela que les
sénateurs sont élus par les grands
électeurs élu aux même c'est pour cela
que l'article 39 dispose que le projet
de loi aant pour principal objet
l'organisation des collectivités
territoriales soit soumis en premier
lieu au Sénat c'est pour cela que
l'article 46 en 4e alinéa dispose que
les lois organiques relatives au Sénat
doivent être votées dans les mêmes
termes par les de assemblées pour cela
que l'article 25 ne pose pas de principe
d'identité absolue du statut des membres
de chaque assemblée vous-même monsieur
le ministre vous l'avez reconnu devant
la commission des Lois du Sénat la
semaine dernière en déclarant je vous
cite c'est dans le rapport qu'un
traitement différencier des sénateurs
conduirait à qualifier ce texte de loi
organique relative au Sénat ce qui
suppose un vote conforme des deux
assemblées merci vous avez dit
l'essentiel auriez-vous depuis changer
d'avis le socialiste Pierre JX en 85
dans les débats sur la loi organique de
85 qui limita cumulle rappelez cela ou
encore Michel Rocard en 96 alors
sénateur je cite normal qu'en France
comme partout ailleurs le Sénat soit
composé d'élu investi de responsabilité
dans les collectivités locales
puisquétant précisément là pour cela au
premier chef et Pierre Moroi notre
ancien collègue le Premier ministre
Pierre MAOI le Sénat représente les
collectivités territoriales dans une
dont tout laisse à penser qu'elle
adoptera de nouvelles limitations du
cumul des mandats il y a nécessité de
trouver un lieu où se confrontent les
intérêts des régions des départements et
des communes et le professeur Guy
Carcasson lui-même chantre du nom cumule
revu pouvoir locaux en 2005 il dit on ne
touche à rien concernant le Sénat mais
dans lequel on se borne enfin à imposer
l'interdiction du cumul pour les députés
beaucoup d'élus de grande collectivité
viseraient alors un mandat sénatorial et
revivent
dans des proportions substantielles par
la simple interdiction du cumul des
députés le Sénat le professeur Didier
MOS le 12 septembre 2013 dans le Figaro
a rappelé tout cela avec une analyse
constitutionnelle tout à fait évidente
mes chers collègues et j'en termine
notre débat transcende les sensibilités
politiques je rappelle ici que 17 sur
les 18 sénateurs RDSE ont contribué à
faire dire le président du Sénat celui
de la commission des lois et le
président de la République ce n'est donc
pas un débat gauche- droite pas
davantage un débat autour de la
modernité de la vie publique mais bien
un débat relatif aux institutions de la
République au bicamérisme à la
représentation de nos territoires je
salue le courage de tous ceux de toute
sensibilité qui disent non à une telle
imposture le courage du président
François repsamen savoir dire non c'est
la marque des vrais hommes d'État ou le
président de la République déclaré
dimanche il y a un moment où ce qui nous
rassemble que ce soit des Gaulistes des
libéraux des radicaux enfin des
républicains c'est une conception
commune de la France et de la République
maises chers collègues mes chers
collègues ne défigurons pas cette
conception de la République au nom
d'intérêts partisans sénatrices et
sénateurs de la République au nom de
tous ce qui nous rassemble au nom de
notre histoire et encore davantage de
l'avenir de cette république que nous
voulons forte rassembleuse respectueuse
je vous demande de rejeter ce texte tel
qu'il nous l'est proposé et d'adresser à
l'exécutif le message de la liberté de
la Haute Assemblée au service de la
République vive le Sénat de la
République vive la
république
merci
merci mes chers
collègues voici le
résultat voici le résultat du scrutin
pour l'élection d'un membre titulaire
représentant la France à l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe
nombre de votants
136 majorité absolue des votants 69
Monsieur Bernard Fournier 126 voix en
conséquence Monsieur Bernard Fournier
ayant obtenu la majorité absolue des
suffrages des votants je le proclame
membre titulaire du Sénat représentant
la France à l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de l'Europe résultat du scrutin
pour l'élection d' membre suppléant du
Sénat représentant la France à
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe nombre de votants 136 majorité
absolue 69 monsieur André Rechard 127
voix en conséquence monsieur Rechard
ayant obtenu la majorité absolue des
suffrages des votants je le proclamme
membre suppléant du Sénat représentant
la France à l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de l'Europe la parole est à
présent à Madame Hélène lipiz pour le
groupe
écologiste monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je sais que j'ai une rue
de tâ pour succéder
mais je pense que vous allez aussi
m'écouter j'espère avec autant
d'enthousiasme parce que voici le texte
celui qui
fâche celui qui Clive celui qui
transcende les familles politiques le
texte visant à empêcher ou à limiter le
cumul des mandats et plus exactement à
limiter le cumul du mandat de
parlementaire avec d'autres mandats ou
fon
élective je ne reviendrai pas
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre sur sur
l'inepsie excusez-moi de ce terme fort
de décider de priver les parlementaires
d'un second tour de parole et de vote de
quoi aviez-vous peur vous le savez
l'assemblée majoritairement derrière
vous et les contestataires du Sénat n'en
peuvent m quant à l'urgence de limiter
le cumul elle est née avec moi en
1958 elle commence donc à vieillir il
n'y avait pas de raison d'avoir une
procédure
accélérée faut-il d'ailleurs croire la
légende qui voudrait que le général de
Gaulle n'a pas voulu interdire le cumul
des mandats pour que les parlementaire
est un Noos à ronger eux que la 5è
République a dépouillé de leur pouvoir
il doit y avoir un fond de vérité
rappelons-nous que Louis XIV a inventé
la cour pour calmer l' belliqueuse et
noble en laissant se développer le
cancer du cumul des mandats comme aucune
autre démocratie européenne ne le
connaît ou comme aucune autre
constitution précédente de la France ne
l'a connu la 5èe République est en
rupture avec son propre principe
démocratie le je cite l'article 2 le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple et
pour le peuple car en confisquant
jusqu'à 20 25 mandats ou fonctions
représentatives les parlementaires qui
cumulent confisquent le gouvernement de
leur
territoire faut-il rappeler le conflit
d'intérêt
évident lorsque certains sénateurs ne
viennent dans cette hémicycle qu'au
moment où nous discutons des lois qui
concernent directement leur territoire
ou leur mandat
lorsqu'il lorsqu'il prépare des pans
entiers d'une loi à deux ou trois
parlementaires d'un même départ
et qu'il parviennent à l'imposer au
Parlement sous couvert d'une expertise
locale ils viennent défendre leur
territoire leur ville ce qui peut être
louable comment les emblamer mais
ont-ils besoin d'un mandat exécutif pour
cela et
surtout défendent-il l'intérêt général
de l'ensemble de la nation d'une nature
par essence différente de l'intérêt
local et et puis où est l'égalité des
candidatures quand un élu cumule ou
souhaite cumuler n'a-t-il pas lui aussi
un pouvoir ou des connaissances qui
rompent l'égalité des candidatures ou
n'a-t-il pas une aura qui n'a pas que
n'a pas un candidat non
cumularard et je le dis sans acrimonie
je peux avoir de l'estime pour ceux qui
cumulent qui font souvent voire même
très souvent un très bon travail mais
qui pour certains ne font pas tout le
travail ou ne le font que par le prisme
de leur territoire et je ne suis pas
certaine et je n'ai certainement pas
pardon de mépris pour eux les
apparatchiques de la politique juste
peut-être un peu de pitié en ne faisant
que de la politique ils oublient qu'il y
a une vie en dehors de celle-ci ils
vivent ils pensent politique or
l'organisation de la vie de la cité la
politique est d'abord une histoire de
citoyens et de citoyennes de rapport
avec avec la société de rapport dans la
cité ce que reproche les Français
françaises c'est que nous soyons
déconnectés de la réalité de ce qu'ils
vivent et même si nous nous penchons sur
leurs problèmes en faisant les marchés
ou sur le terrain lors de notre
permanence nous ne faisons plus partie
de la société civile mais de la société
politique et cette différence les
Français françaises le ressentent comme
jamais à même intensité auupar avant
peut-être parce qu'avant le niveau
d'instruction était moindre mais aussi
parce qu'internet permet au peuple de
s'exprimer en dehors des
élections même les élus non cumulars
reprochent à ceux qui cumulent de ne pas
être des élus tout à fait comme eux être
sénateur et maire conseiller régional et
maire même d'une petite commune ouvre
des portes qui ne sont pas ouvertes au
détenteur d'un seul mandat un député
maire me faisait part de la difficult
comme maire d'une sous-préfecture de
s'imposer face à la technocratie
étatique attitude qui a un tout petit
peu changé depuis qu'il est
parlementaire donc le cumul est
peut-être aussi une réponse à l'énarchie
mais dans ce cas n'est-ce pas l'en qu'il
faut changer et non pas la règle du non
cumul certes parmi les élus cumulant ou
non il y a des apparatiques des partis
et cela dans tous les partis des
apparats chics de la politique et cela
dans tous les partis politiques et des
parachutés qui arrivent dans une
circonscription avec les beaux àours de
leur parti sont aussi condamnables que
les bibind d'homes ses élus empilant les
écharpes autour de leur table de leur
taille pardon pour éviter que le
naufrage de leur mandat ne les condamne
à redevenir de simples citoyens le cumul
des mandats leur permettant ainsi de
surnager en l'absence d'un véritable
statut de élu alors oui je peux
comprendre que certains parce qu'il n'y
a pas de statut d'élu et que donc la fin
du mandat fait peur parce que le
Parlement est rabaissé et donc les
parlementaires avec les 6itard
d'ailleurs l'avaient bien compris que
certains donc cumulle par volonté de
servir leur idée leurs concitoyens mais
aussi et il faut bien l'avouer par
besoin de reconnaissance et soap du
pouvoir il est ainsi étonnant de
constater adéquation entre le ressenti
des citoyens et celui des électe des
élus qui cumulent les journaux les
citoyens Landa traite ses élus de
cumular et c'est vrai que c'est un
mauvais terme un terme quelque peu
démagogique qui ne me plaît absolument
pas pas plus que me plaît le palmarès
qui a été publié récemment mais ceux qui
cumulent témoignent parfois d'un profond
mépris envers ceux qui ont fait le choix
de ne pas accumuler et nous sommes
nombreux dans ce cas ou de ceux qui
n'ont pas pu être cumularard puisqu'il y
a plus de 400000 élus en France et qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul milliers gros petits
milliers de postes de parlementaires
comme si les nom cumulat non seulement
dans l'espace mais aussi parfois dans le
temps avait moins de valeur car élu
moins souvent comme si leur travail
était moins efficace ou moins noble
alors même qu'il se consacre à un seul
mandat tant sur les terrains que dans
l'hémicycles
certes ceux qui cumulent dans le temps
ou dans l'espace le font avec l'onction
du suffrage universel ils sont légitimer
ainsi à leurs propres yeux il faut
toutefois garder à l'esprit que les
électeurs n'ont pas vraiment le choix
des candidats pour qui ils peuvent voter
et que ce sont bien les partis qui
choisissent les candidats en faisant des
cumulat aussi eux-mêmes des apparatiques
de ces
partis même dans le cas de primaire
ouver verte le filtre de ces primaires
est déterminé par les par entre un
candidat ayant déjà une cquette qui
représente vos idées et un candidat sans
casquette et qui représente des idées
auxquelles vous êtes opposé le choix
semble simple jusqu'au jour où le nom
cumule devient pour vous simple citoyen
le critère de choix parce que vous êtes
persuadé à tort ou à raison qu'en
tumulant l'élu ne peut pas travailler
pour vous mais travaille pour lui et
surtout connaî plus les réalités du
terrain certains conçoivent le cumul
comme une exigence constitutionnelle le
Sénat assure la représentation des
collectivités territoriales de la
République ce qui légitimerait que tous
sénateurs allont jusqu'au bout soit un
situation de cumul outre le fait que
rien n'interdit de comprendre cet
article constitutionnel comme une simple
exigence de connaissance des
collectivités territoriales au travers
notamment d'un précédent mandat
l'interprétation de la nécessité d'avoir
un mandat territorial pour être sénateur
aurait comme colorolaire nécessaire et
évident que le Sénat ne pourrait
délibérer que sur les textes relevant
des collectivités territoriales
inversement l'assemblée qui
représenterait le peuple ne pourrait pas
avoir en son sein de représentation des
collectivités territorial et surtout ne
pourrait pas délibérer sur
l'organisation de celle-ci l'absurdité
de ce raisonnement extrême se de plus un
autre article de la Constitution
l'article 3 qui dit qu'aucune section du
peuple ici le Sénat car nous faisons
quand même partie du peuple ne peut
s'attribuer l'exercice de la
souveraineté nationale fut-elle réduite
à l'organisation des collectivité
territoriale aujourd'hui un sénateur
homme ou femme sans mandat territorial
en cours à la plénitude de la
connaissance pour traiter des
collectivités territoriales comme un
sénateur a des idées sur le droit des
femmes comme une sénatrice sur celui des
hommes enfin du moins je
l'espère reste l'efficacité du travail
politique et c'est sur cette efficacité
que nous sommes jugés travailler à
organiser sa ville à la faire devenir
une métropole nationale voire européenne
est certainement plus facile que
qu'influencer la politique nationale par
le travail parlementaire et nous en
savons quel chose ici au Sénat le
pouvoir politique aujourd'hui n'est plus
au Parlement mais dans les collectivités
territoriales alors même qu'ell
connaissent les mêmes difficultés
budgétaires le désintérêt de certains
parlementaires à venir siéger
régulièrement en commission ou en
hémicycle est peut-être dû à
l'affaiblissement du Parlement et à la
présidentialisation du pouvoir en France
mais alors pour revaloriser la fonction
parlementaire ne faut-il pas commencer
par revaloriser le Parlement et donc
changer de
constitution alors non monsieur le
ministre ce que vous nous proposez dans
ce texte n'est pas la querelle des
anciens et des modernes ce n'est pas une
question de prendre ses responsabilités
quels que soi nos votes ils seront ici
en conscience ce que vous nous proposez
monsieur le ministre c'est une
transformation de notre paysage mental
et un changement de notre paysage
politique pour les écologistes le nom
cumule est inscrit dans nos gènes et
dans nos statuts même si parfois j'en
suis bien consciente comme dans d'autres
parties il y a des exceptions qui
confirment la règle puisque nous sommes
en France parce que les écologistes dou
rveur pense qu'il faut partager les
mandats partager la représentation pour
qu'elle soit plus diverse nous nous
voterons donc ce votre texte monsieur le
ministre avec la conscience aigue que
nous sommes un train de transformer
former petit à petit texte par texte la
5è République de la détricoter parce
qu'elle est à bout de souffle et que que
nous n'avons pas le courage de dire
qu'il faut la qu'il faut changer la
constitution de la France frembloyante
de 1958 qui n'est plus adapté à la
France du 21e siècle dans une Europe
plus présente et où les citoyens et
peut-être surtout les citoyenne appelle
à un autre rapport à la
politique peut-être moins
virile peut-être moins MTU vu et plus
proche d'eux nous voterons donc ce texte
en ayant connaissance qu'il s'agit d'un
nouveau coup de couteau dans une outre
qui se vide peu à peu de ce contenu pour
abreuver les réflexions sur la Nouvelle
République que nous appelons de notre
vœux merci la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Jean-Louis Masson pour le
groupe des non
inscrit
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues le cumul des mandats et son
corollaire direct l'absentéisme
parlementaire sont deux particularités
bien françaises deux deux particularités
affligeantes qui nuisent au bon
fonctionnement de la démocratie un
mandat de député ou de sénateur
correspond à un travail à plein
il en est de même pour une fonction de
maire de grande ville de président de
communauté d'agglomération ou de
président de conseil général or nul ne
peut assumer correctement deux activités
qui sont chacune à pleinemps cependant
les élus qui profitent du système sont
aussi nombreux à droite qu'à gauche et
c'est l'explication du combat
d'arrière-garde qui est engagé par ceux
qui s'accroche au
statut pour eux tous les prétextes sont
bons ainsi dans le Figaro du 9 juillet
2012 un cumular a même affirmé que les
sénateurs qui ne cumulent pas une
fonction exécutive local ne sont et je
cite que des élus hors sol coupés de la
gestion quotidienne des collectivité
merci pour moi et bien un autre a même
prétendu que seuls les Apparates chics
des partis seront dorénavant élu
sénateur pour ma part je ne cumule pas
mais je ne suis pas un apparaque et j'ai
quand même été élu sénateur pour ma part
suite à mon élection de sénateur en 2001
j'ai
démissionné bon on peut s'exprimer bon
on est quand même en démocratie bon je
sais qu'il y a plus de cumulur que de
pas cumulur dans cette assemblée mais
ceux qui sont contre le cumule ont quand
même le droit de s'exprimer bon pour ma
part pour ma part suite à mon à mon
élection de sénateur en 2001 j'ai
démissionné afin de ne pas cumuler une
fonction exécutive locale je suis donc
devenu un élu soi-disant hors sol
ilempêche lors des élections
sénatoriales de 2011 sans aucune
investiture d'aucun parti politique j'ai
largement devancé les deux autres listes
de droite qui elle avaiit une
investiture était qui et qui était
conduite par des élus super cumularards
en fait c'est parce que je ne cumule pas
un exécutif local que j'ai le temps de
me consacrer pleinement à mon mandat de
sénateur que j'ai le temps de m'occuper
des réalités du terrain en visitant les
communes partout dans le département de
la Moselle de plus en étant simple
conseiller général de base on est
largement au contact du quotidien et il
faut être d'une totale mauvaise foi pour
prétendre le contraire en fait le cumul
de mandat permet à celui qui en abuse
d'étouffer la démocratie par une
concentration abusive des pouvoirs tout
en profitant d'avantage matériel et
financiers considérable en effet un
député ou un sénateur qui est maire de
grande ville ou président de conseil
général a des moyens démesurément
supérieur à ceux d'un parlementaire de
base certains font même prendre en
charge par la collectivité locale de
nombreuses dépenses telles que
secrétariat voiture de fonction
téléphone frais de restaurant ou autres
qu'il serait sinon obligé de financer
personnellement sur leur indemnité ou
sur leur
leurfm enfin je rappelle aussi que la
super concentration des pouvoirs qui est
liée au cumul abusif est un des
principaux facteurs de corruption parmi
les élus ainsi une statistique évoquée
sur la chaîne de radio Europe 1 le 3
avril 2013 indique que 90 % des
parlementaires poursuivis pour
corruption ou autres malversation sont
des parlementaires en situation de cumul
dans la mesure où environ 55 dans la
mesure où environ 55 % des
parlementaires sont concernés par le
cumul un simple calcul montre qu'un
parlementaire qui cumule une fonction
exécutive locale a 7,4 fois plus de
chance qu'un autre d'être poursuivi pour
malversation en interdisant les cumules
abusifs de mandat ce projet de loi
contribue donc à moraliser la vie
publique à promouvoir une véritable
respiration démocratique et à réduire
l'absentéisme parlementaire toutefois
monsieur le ministre je regrette que le
gouvernement ait reporté son application
à 2017 pour les députés à 2019 pour les
parlementaires européens et à 2020 pour
certains sénateurs cette excellente
réforme aurait dû s'appliqué dès les
municipales de 2014 ce qui l'aurait
enraciné de manière
irréversible en conclusion il est
évident que la limitation des cumuls de
mandat répond à une aspiration forte
d'une majorité écrasante de nos
concitoyens je tiens donc à vous
féliciter monsieur le ministre pour la
détermination dont vous avez fait preuve
en résistant aux pressions des
cumularards de tout bords qui
s'accrochent de manière pathétique au
prébandes qu'il retirre de cette
anomalie démocratique ainsi vous avez eu
raison de refuser qu'on introduise une
dérogation concernant les fonctions de
maire de commune jusqu'à 20000 ou 30000
habitants les instigateurs de cette idée
parlaient hypocritement de petites
communes mais en fait avec 200000 ou
30000 habitants et en ajoutant les
responsabilités intercommunales on est
très loin d'une logique de petites
communes monsieur le ministre vous avez
eu encore plus raison de refuser la
création d'une exception au profit des
sénateur l'image du Sénat est déjà pas
très positive dans l'opinion publique et
il faut vraiment beaucoup d'inconscience
pour imaginer un régime dérogatoire
permettant au seuls sénateurs cumular de
continuer à profiter du système pour ma
part et par dignité vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens je n'aurais jamais osé
proposer une telle disposition
qui reviendrait pour le Sénat à se
servir lui-même enfin Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai 10 lignes enfin Monsieur
le Ministre j'ai deux regrets le premier
comme je vous l'ai déjà indiqué c'est la
date trop tardive d'entrée en vigueur de
ce projet de loi qui qui seéchonnera de
2017 à 2020 la seconde est pour déplorer
que strictement rien ne soit prévu pour
encadrer les cumuls d'exécutifs locaux
par exemple on pourra continuer à être
maire de très grande ville président de
communauté urbaine et vice-président de
conseil régional trois exécutifs de
cette taille cela dépasse vraiment le
raisonnable et je souhaiterais monsieur
le ministre que vous vous expliquiez sur
cette carence merci la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Philippe B pour le
groupe
UMP oui
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez tout à l'heure plus ou moins
aimablement invité à la
réflexion j'espère que en écoutant nos
excellents collègues les présidents
zoketo et mesar vous vous serez laisser
convaincre en dépit de toute votre
détermination que la réflexion et plutôt
du côté de ceux qui rappellent nos
traditions républicaines que de ceux qui
voudraient faire la loi avec des idées
reçues et des lieux
communs mon groupe aborde la
question de la limitation du cumul des
mandats dans un esprit
constructif tous dans cette assemblée
nous sommes d'ailleurs conscients que
les cumuls excessifs
serait aussi néfaste au Parlement qu'aux
collectivités territorial elle-même ça
n'est pas ce qui nous sépare il faut
aussi tirer les conséquences de la
montée en puissance des
intercommunalités la réforme de 2010 que
vous avez tellement critiqué accroit
encore cette nécessité comme de nombreux
membres de mon groupe je me suis
d'ailleurs souvent exprimé dans le sens
d'une actualisation des règles de cumul
ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous soyons
prêts a accepté n'importe
quoi l'interdiction absolue d'exercer
une fonction exécutive locale nous
paraîtrait aussi excessive et absurde
que la liberté absolue qui existait
avant
1985 nous refusons d'envoyer le
balancier d'un extrême à l'autre nous
sommes pour la recherche d'un
équilibre le Sénat a d'ailleurs t
toujours été ouvert sur cette question
il a contribué à la limitation du cumul
des mandats même quand il était dans
l'opposition au gouvernement qui en
prenait l'initiative ce de Monsieur
Fabius et de Monsieur Jospin il a ainsi
voté les lois de 1985 et de 2000 qui ont
établi et étendu le régime des
incompatibilités entre mandat locaux et
nationaux et plafonner le montant des
indemnités pouvant être perçu par un
parlementaire ces lois ont déjà
drastiquement réduit le nombre de
cumules possies elles ont fait l'objet
d'un large consensus était adopté
monsieur le ministre soyez-y attentif
s'il vous plaît en terme identique par
les deux assemblées ce que vos
prédécesseurs ont réussi à obtenir vous
pouvez vous aussi si vous é mettez de la
bonne volonté le
réussir c'était il est vrai une période
de la 5e République où où le
gouvernement recherchait autant qu'il le
pouvait un accord du Parlement Assemblée
nationale et Sénat sans considérer la
représentation nationale comme une
simple couroie de transmission
aujourd'hui encore un consensus serait
possible si le Gouvernement et
l'Assemblée nationale voulit bien s'en
donner la peine nous pensons qu'une
fonction exécutive local et un mandat
parlementaire peuvent se compléter
utilement dans l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens l'accès aux grands centres
de décision nationaux la connaissance et
la pratique des grands enjeux de la
politique nationale sont profitables au
territoirees et à leurs habitants
inversement la responsabilité
opérationnel de services publics locaux
est utile à l'exercice de mandat
parlementaire elle favorise des
approches peut-être moins idéologique et
militante que vous ne le souhaiteriez
mais plus indépendante plus pragmatique
plus
responsable l'idée que les
parlementaires libérés de leur fonction
local pourrai davantage participer à des
Activ des activités bénévoles et
associatives utiles à leur connaissance
du terrain est sympathique mais ces
expériences ne sauraient remplacer
l'exercice de responsabilité publique et
il faut choisir entre les arguments on
ne peut vouloir à la fois que le temps
libéré soit consacré à la fonction
parlementaire et qu' servent en même
temps à des activités associatives de
terrain le lien entre élus nationaux et
citoyens ne serait en aucun cas renforcé
par l'interdiction d'exercer une
fonction exécutive locale c'est le
contraire il serait grandement affaibli
et de cela nous ne voulons pas la vérité
c'est que vous répondez à
l'antiparlementarisme par populisme en
accréditant
que ni les
parlementaires ni les responsables
politiques not ne font correctement leur
travail aujourd'hui quand ils assument
en même temps ces deux activités
pourtant complémentaires or rien ne
vérifie ce postulat au contraire un
grand nombre de collègues qui ne
figurent pas parmi les moins assidus
sont également très présents dans leur
département au titre de leur
responsabilité locale
notre engagement public ne se divise pas
nous y consacrons autant de temps
personnel que de temps équivalent au
temps professionnel nous ne sommes pas
soumis à la législation sur la durée du
travail nous ne sommes pas au 35 he nous
aimons ce que nous faisons et le faisons
sans compter c'est le seul privilège que
nous
revendiquons les causes de
l'antiparlementarisme ne réside
d'ailleurs pas principalement dans le
statut ou le comportement des élus sauf
dans des cas
exceptionnels que nous savons dénoncer
avec force elle réside plus sûrement
dans le sentiment de l'impuissance
publique en particulier en matière de
lutte contre
l'insécurité en matière
d'emploi en matière de pouvoir d'achat
voilà les vraies urgences pour les
Français
ce projet souffre de sur croix
d'incohérence majeure s'il était adopté
un maire continuerait à se voir garantir
par le Code du travail comme par le
statut des fonctionnaires de pouvoir
exercer une activité professionnelle
salarié à 75 % au moins de son temps de
travail soit 28 he il pourrait aussi
bien poursuivre toute activité
professionnelle indépendante très
prenante mais il n'aurait le droit
d'être ni député ni sénateur
son activité privée serait donc mieux
traité qu'une activité publique et je ne
parle pas des cumuls de mandats locaux
qui permettent pourtant
actuellement président mard l'a rappelé
à quelques élus de percevoir des
indemnités plus élevées que celle d'un
parlementaire et nullement réglementé et
vous ne proposez pas de le faire quant
au parlementaires il continue à
bénéficier du principe du libre exercice
d'une profession dans les limites
prévues par les
incompatibilités récemment réexaminé par
le Parlement il pourrait aussi exercer
d'importantes responsabilités nationale
dans un parti politique on lui
permettrait également d'assurer la
présidence d'organismes nationaux
Fédération Hospitalière fédération de
logement social Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation Centre national de la
fonction publique territoriale
ubiance mais il ne pourrait être ni
maire d'une commune fut-elle une commune
de 200 habitants ni vice-président d'un
conseil général ni président de conseil
régional et l'on voit ici que derrière
l'apparente simplicité du projet du
gouvernement se cache la plus grande
confusion intellectuelle voilà la
réflexion qu'on peut faire et les plus
grandes contradiction dans tous les cas
des activités pouvant être fortement
rémunérées bénéficieraient d'un
traitement privilégié par rapport à
l'exercice de mandat public au service
des
Français sans parler d'hypocrisie ou
d'imposture on peut tout de même relever
que votre projet agite les symboles
politiques sans traiter en profondeur
les réalités les Français ne tarderont
pas à s'en apercevoir gare aux effets
boomerang c'est par ce genre de faux
semblant qu'on nourrit
l'antiparlementarisme nous ne souhaitons
pas par principe différencier les
sénateurs des députés nous souhaiterions
même que des règles identiques
continuent à leur être appliqué en
matière d'incompatibilité comme c'est le
cas non pas depuis toujours mais tout de
même depuis
1887 c'est le gouvernement et
l'Assemblée nationale qui par leur
intransigence leur position extrême
révolutionnaire avez-vous dit nous
impose d'envisager cette solution nous
sommes cependant soucieux de donner
toutes ces chances au maintien d'un
régime de limitation des cumuls commun
aux membres des deux assemblées c'est
pourquoi nous avons déposé un amendement
permettant l'exercice d'une fonction
exécutive locale par les uns et par les
autres aut cet amendement apporterait
des restrictions importantes aux règles
actuell du cumul serait notamment
englober toutes les fonctions de maire
et d'adjoint de président de
vice-président d'intercommunalité et
cetera et cetera et notamment les
vice-présidents de conseils
départementaux et régionaux aucune de
ces fonctions n'est actuellement prise
en compte cela constituerait donc une
évolution importante et en même temps
acceptable du point de vue de nos
institutions la seule différence avec
avec le texte de l'Assemblée nationale
résiderait dans la possibilité d'exercer
l'une de ces fonctions tout en restant
parlementaire nous avons conscience que
la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qui
s'est clairement exprimé en faveur d'un
choix plus radical n'acceptera pas
facilement cet amendement surtout si le
gouvernement ne l'approuve pas au Sénat
mon groupe l'a cependant déposé en signe
de bonne volonté pour inviter le
gouvernement à ne pas se montrer fermé
et à rechercher un compromis raisonnable
avec tous les groupes du Sénat nous
avons cependant conscience que cette
option est la plus contraire au choix du
président de la République et au premier
vote de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
pourquoi nous proposerons un autre
amendement introduisant une distinction
entre députés et sénateur en matière de
cumul et laissant l'Assemblée nationale
adopter un régime plus restrictif si
elle le souhaite pour les députés si la
France a choisi d'avoir un régime
bicaméral c'est dans l'intérêt d'une
discussion parlementaire de qualité
pour faire de meilleures lois c'est
aussi parce que à côté de l'Assemblée
nationale représentant directement le
peuple nous avons voulu avoir une
assemblée démocratique elle aussi
représentant les territoires à travers
leur collectivité et aussi ne les
oublions pas les Français de l'étranger
le lien entre les sénateurs et les
territoires est donc inscrit au cœur de
l'identité du Sénat c'est l'article 24
de la Constitution le Sénat représente
les collectivités territoriales de la
République et les Français de l'étranger
comprenez que nous y soyons
viscéralement attachés notre légitimité
en dépend pleinement parlementaire nous
sommes aussi Mair parmi les maires élus
locaux parmi les élus locaux ce qui
n'est déjà pas souhaitable pour les
députés serait donc inconcevable pour
les sénateurs le bicamérisme n'est
certes pas obligatoire c'est une
organisation constitutionnelle dont on
peut débattre mais il n'a en tout cas
d'intérêt que si l'identité de chaque
assemblée est respectée avec son apport
particulier la différenciation que nous
proposons et sommes tout assez modestes
inéligligibilité incompatibilité
resteront identique seule différence le
député ne pourra exercer qu'un mandat
délibératif local comme l'assemblée l'a
voulu le sénateur pourra en revanche
avoir un mandat exécutif comme nous
souhaitons que le Sénat le décide cette
différence et d'ailleurs justifié par
d'autres spécificités du Sénat elles ont
été rappelées tout à l'heure par le
Président mesard je n'y revient pas
monsieur le ministre pour nous dissuader
d'adopter cette
solution on vient parfois nous dire vous
l'avez fait tout à l'heure avec une
certaine véhémence d'ailleurs qu'une
différence de plus parmi tant d'autres
pourrait à terme conduire à une remise
en cause du Sénat alors que cette
différence serait circonscrite à ce que
j'ai dit la seule possibilité pour les
sénateurs d'exercer une fonction
exécutive locale ce qui n'est pas
consubstantiel à la définition du statut
commun des parlementaires hérité de la
tradition républicaine et qui
respecterait la vocation propre du Sénat
il y aurait dans cet argument de
dissuasion une menace grave et et
inacceptable pour nos institutions parce
que nous sommes par construction
indépendants et libre nous sommes
heureusement insensibles à ce genre de
pression et nous le sommes d'autant
moins que faut-il le rappeler aucune
révision constitutionnelle ne peut se
faire sans notre accord il me faut avant
de conclure dire un mot de la procédure
législative plusieurs de nos collègues
ont bien fait de rappeler que le recours
à la procédure accélérée pour un texte
qui n'entrera en vigueur qu'à partir de
2017 n'est en rien justifieré considère
même qu'il s'agit d'un abus de droit les
conditions d'examen de ce texte ont été
exécra le rapport de notre rapporteur a
été examiné par la commission dans des
conditions improvisées vous nous dites
que le Président de la République a
annoncé cette réforme pendant sa
campagne électorale que cela fait
longtemps qu'on en parle que les
positions des uns et des autres sont
déjà connu soit mais cela ne vaut pas
dispense d'une délibération
parlementaire approfondie ce type
d'argument est très choquant en réalité
il ne cesse d'être invoquer comme si
certains pensaient que le Parlement est
de trop et que le vote de la loi ne
devrait plus être qu'une formalité aussi
vite expédié qu'un conseil des
ministres le recours à la procédure
accélérée n'est d'ailleurs pas seulement
une entrave au plein exercice des droits
du Parlement c'est aussi une manière de
faire délibérer le Sénat sous la menace
de donner le dernier mot à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est particulièrement
choquant quand la matière d'un projet
concerne les sénateurs en même temps que
les députés mais en
l'occurrence c'est de toute façon en
pure perte que le gouvernement ferait
peser cette menace car son projet
comporte déjà une disposition organique
spécifique au sénateurs elle concerne le
remplacement des sénateurs qui sont élus
au scrutin majoritaire et qui
abandonneraient leur mandat
parlementaire pour une fonction
exécutive locale vous pourriez renoncer
à cette disposition mais monsieur le
ministre je pense que vous ne le ferez
pas vous auriez trop peur que des
élections partielles vous fassent perdre
une majorité déjà courte et fragile au
Sénat mais il y a davantage plusieurs
amendements dont le nôtre définissent un
régime particulier
d'incompatibilité pour les sénateurs si
le Sénat devait adopter l'un de ses
amendements il va de soit que son vote
priverait le gouvernement du droit de
passer en force avec la complicité de
l'Assemblée nationale car le projet
aurait plus sûrement encore le caractère
de loi organique relative au Sénat
l'analyse juridique est simple je ne
vous l'épargnerai pas monsieur le
ministre mais vous la connaissez bien
vous y avez fait référence vous-même
l'article LO 297 du code électoral qui
aligne jusqu'à présent l'intégralité du
régime des incompatibilités des
sénateurs celui des députés ne peut
entraîner l'application de nouvelles
incompatibilités au sénateurs par la
seule volonté de l'Assemblée nationale
si le Sénat décide le contraire par un
vote modifiant cet article de loi
organique relative au Sénat sinon la
garantie du 4e paragraphe de l'article
46 de la Constitution ultime rempart des
droits du Sénat serait en réalité vidé
de toute substance au mépris de la
volonté des constituant je rappelle les
termes je rappelle les termes de cette
disposition constitutionnelle les lois
organique relativ au Sénat doivent être
voté dans les mêmes thèmes par les deux
assemblées c'est clair la jurisprudence
du Conseil constitutionnel sur
l'application de cette disposition
quoique restrictive ne saurait permettre
à l'Assemblée nationale non seulement
d'empêcher l'application au sénateur
d'une disposition organique spécifique
au Sénat qu'ils aurai adopté mais encore
de leur imposer dans un même élan une
disposition organique générale qu'ils
auraient expressément refusé ce serait
par trop contraire à l'esprit et la
lettre de la Constitution qui a
précisément entendu préserver les droits
du Sénat sur toute question de nature
organique le concernant spécifiquement
l'article LO 297 n'est pas un ch en
blanc du Sénat pour l'éternité il ne
peut valoir à priori pour toute
modification à venir du régime des
incompatibilités adopté en 1985 dans sa
forme actuelle pour un état donné de ses
incompatibilités il a été maintenu tel
quel lors des modifications qui toutes
ont été approuvées par le Sénat sans
jamais donner le dernier mot à
l'Assemblée nationale ce serait donc la
première fois qu'il permettrait
l'application Sénat de règles que
celui-ci aurait rejeté pour lui-même
cette réalité juridique s'impose à tous
la portée de l'article 46 de la
Constitution est d'ailleurs pleinement
reconnu par le gouvernement lui-même
monsieur le ministre lors de votre
audition tout à fait spontanément devant
la commission des lois le 10 septembre
dernier vous avez justement et avec une
grande honnêteté intellectuelle énoncé
sans détour et de la manière la plus
plus clair l'interprétation qu'il
convient de lui donner en déclarant je
vous cite exactement qu'un traitement
différencié des sénateurs changerait la
qualification juridique de la loi
organique sur le cumul elle serait
inévitablement considéré par le
Conseil comme une décision relative au
Sénat imposant un vote conforme des deux
assemblées je ne doute pas que ce sera
votre
uite il n'y a donc aucune ambigué le
dernier mot ne pourra revenir à
l'Assemblée nationale si le Sénat
différencie les règles nouvelles
applicables au mandat locaux des
sénateurs par rapport à celles qui
s'appliqueraiit au députés aucune autre
lecture de la Constitution n'est
recevable c'est dire que nous allons
délibérer dans dans le plein exercice
l'exercice intégral de nos prérogatives
parlementaires dans une égalité totale
avec l'Assemblée nationale si celle-ci
devait modifier ou supprimer une
disposition de loi organique relative au
Sénat que nous aurions adopté nous
aurions donc nécessairement à nous
prononcer de nouveau pour parvenir à une
rédaction commune et nous le ferions
avec cet état d'esprit constructif que
j'ai rappelé en commençant cette
intervention je conclus monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
dit votre fierté de présenter ce projet
au Parlement c'est aussi avec fierté
certain de servir notre idéal
républicain que nous nous y opposons
d'ailleurs comme toutes les grandes
personnalités politiques de notre pays
vous avez su concilier vos mandats de
députés de responsables d'un grand parti
politique et de maire d'une grande ville
d'autres vous l'avez rappelé été
président de conseil général ni eux ni
ni vous n'exprimiez alors aucune espèce
de contriction ni le moindre remord vous
ne donniez d'ailleurs pas non plus de
signe public d'épuisement vous
manifestiez au contraire beaucoup
d'enthousiasme pour l'exercice de vos
mandats complémentaire vos électeurs
vous suivaient puissiez-vous aujourd'hui
retrouver cet enthousiasme nous sommes
nombreux à le partager dans la passion
du service des
Français
merci
voilà pour cette séance qui s'est
déroulée mi-septembre au Sénat vous avez
pu le voir il y a eu un véritable
face-à-face entre manuel Vals le
ministre de l'Intérieur venu défendre
son projet de loi sur le non cumul des
mandats et face à lui Jacques mzard
président du groupe RDSE le ce groupe à
majorité de radicaux de gauche et vous
pouvez bien sûr toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires